Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
In welcher Instanz treibst du dich eigentlich so rum?
Völlig egal, um fünf ist Weltuntergang und der ist für alle gleich.
Buchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertfünfundsiebzig vom vierten Januar zweitausendundeinundzwanzig. Da ist es, lang ersehnt das neue Jahr.
Wir haben's alle gebraucht, jetzt ist es da, jetzt geht's uns besser, einfach so.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass jetzt die ähm.
Verschiedene Kolumisten äh sich jetzt auch langsam als äh Anhängerinnen äh äußern und von den goldenen oder den wilden wilden Zwanzigern sprechen, ne.
Ja klar. Ist doch immer das.
Glauben dir auch jeden Scheiß, e.
Ja, also ach Mann. Ja, irgendwann, irgendwann äh kommen sie alle hinterher irgendwie bei Techno hat's ein paar Jahre gedauert, Podcast.
Jetzt auch das. Ich kenne das nicht anders.
Ja, ist natürlich jetzt ein heißes Thema, ne? Klar, logisch, aber schauen wir mal. Vielleicht dauert's ja auch noch ein bisschen, aber ich bin nach wie vor zuversichtlich, weil man muss sowieso,
zuversichtlich sein, weil wenn man nicht zuversichtlich ist, dann ist sowieso alles verloren.
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, wenn man nicht Zufall äh sichtlich ist, dann wird man einfach halt also so ein so ein Grieskram.
Ja, da wird man total.
Dann mag einen keiner mehr. Das ist meine größte Sorge, ehrlich gesagt.
Dies berechtigt.
Ja, dass ich irgendwie so ein, dass ich auch mal so einer werde. Aber zum Glück habe ich also ich habe die die goldenen Zwanziger noch vor mir, also wenn ich irgendwann hier.
Ob du mal zu lebensaltermäßig.
Zwanzig neunundzwanzig irgendwann sagen muss, Tim, hör auf mit deinen goldenen Pflanzen. Ich kann die Scheiße nicht mehr hören, ne.
Und das dann dann äh glaube ich, dann gebe ich auch langsam die Hoffnung auf.
Ja, mal schauen.
Lassen wir es einfach auf uns äh zukommen. So wie wir auch in diesem Jahr die ähm tja, wie soll man es nennen? Ersatzveranstaltungen. Ähm,
RC drei auf uns haben zukommen lassen und alle nicht so richtig wussten.
Was wir denn da jetzt eigentlich ähm zu erwarten haben und dann wahrscheinlich mehrheitlich wir zumindest, glaube ich, so ein bisschen alle Erwartungen auch einfach mal ausgesetzt haben, wovon äh reden wir natürlich von dem,
Event, was quasi zum selben Zeitpunkt stattfand, wo sonst normalerweise ein Chaos Communication Kongress gewesen wäre,
uns alle wild eingebunden hätte und äh viel Schlaf geraubt hätte und überhaupt. Aber äh aber auch wiederum sehr glücklich gemacht hätte und jetzt durch Corona war es natürlich unmöglich, diese Veranstaltung durchzuführen.
Und.
Ja, ein Ruf ging aus in dieser Community, sich doch darüber Gedanken zu machen, was man stattdessen tun konnte, während ich persönlich, ehrlich gesagt, so am Anfang mir dachte, so,
Vielleicht ist einfach so eine Fehlstelle auch mal ganz geil. Vielleicht ist es einfach auch mal ganz richtig, einfach mal gar nix zu machen, uns einfach nur zu vermissen.
Und ähm wahrscheinlich ist das schon eine Sicht in gewisser Hinsicht so eine etwas privilegierte Sichtweise. Ja, weil.
Hängt ja dann immer selbst von einem ab und von den Umständen auch.
Wie man so in andere Sachen eingebunden ist oder wie man überhaupt die Zeit so empfindet oder wie man überhaupt damit klarkommt und das muss natürlich nicht notwendigerweise für alle genauso gelten.
Ja und dann ist wieder das passiert, was eigentlich immer passiert. Ähm.
Paar Leute haben sich gefunden, haben's gemacht.
Ja, ein paar Leute haben sich gefunden und es gemacht. Und wer macht, hat recht. Das ist so ein bisschen so eins äh vielleicht auch das Wichtigste, so in dieser ganzen Chaos-Community. Nichtsdestotrotz hat sich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel,
Aber ich habe dann halt auch irgendwie einfach meine Erwartungen.
Mir gedacht so OK dann gucken wir doch mal was dabei rauskommt. Vielleicht ist es ja gar nicht so schlimm. Weil warum sage ich das überhaupt? Weil.
Ich habe jetzt so über den Lauf des Jahres viel, na, was heißt viel? Bin auch, glaube ich, viel aus dem Weg gegangen, aber alles, was so an.
Online-Konferenzding stattfand, dass.
Mich irgendwie nicht so gerufen. Deshalb war mir einfach zu viel Talking Hads und zu viel äh Videoscreens und zu viel Zoom und zu viel.
Zu viel, zu wenig in gewisser Hinsicht, also zu viel von all dem, was am Ende dann doch irgendwie zu wenig war, weil ich halt immer nach der mir dachte so
Event, da kommt man doch zusammen wegen der Community und nicht wegen irgendwelcher Talks oder so, sondern da muss man ja irgendwie dieses Lagerfeuergefühl haben und da muss man das Gefühl haben, die anderen wieder zu sehen und und und diese Nähe ist ja doch, doch wichtig und und
Das macht's doch aus und das das kann man doch irgendwie unmöglich ähm.
Oder eben nur mit, weiß ich nicht, mit einem gewissen Aufwand herstellen oder auch nicht. Na ja, stellt sich raus.
Community ist das, glaube ich, nachhaltig gelungen, genau das herzustellen und das finde ich wirklich bemerkenswert.
Ich habe ähm wie alle so,
mich von außen rangetastet, um dann mal zu gucken, was denn da eigentlich läuft und am Ende musste ich feststellen, dass wir wieder es war schon wieder,
sehr geiles Event, was was wirklich Maßstäbe gesetzt hat, auf eine Art und Weise, wie's, ja, wie ich einfach damit nicht gerechnet habe.
Kann das ruhig ehrlich sein, sagen zu, du warst äh,
sehr angetan und sehr überzeugt von der Idee, dass ausfallen zu lassen und du hast überhaupt keine Chance gesehen, dass das ein Erfolg werden könnte. Das kannst du ruhig zugeben,
und ich bin auch, also ich bin ähm selber äh ehrlich, ich war äh dafür, das zu machen, aber natürlich zwischenzeitlich auch von irgendwie enormer äh Sorge geprägt, dass das irgendwie.
Ja, eine eine Bauchlandung werden könnte, ist ja ganz klar. Ähm.
Äh aber ja am Ende kann man ja dann immer sehen so äh sämtliche Sorgen waren äh wirklich ähm,
ja relativ unbegründet, also es ist jetzt nicht alles äh reibungslos gelaufen, wie wie auch völlig normal ist bei Chaos-Events. Aber ich denke, worauf er ja eigentlich hinausfordert, worauf du vor allem hinaus willst, ist ja eben was war da?
Außerdem, wo klar war, dass es der CCC hinkriegen würde. Was klar war, dass der CCC das hinkriegen würde, war,
Leute, was weiß ich, ne, halten Vorträge bei sich zu Hause oder auf einer leeren Bühne,
und das Ganze wird gestreamt. Das ist so der Teil, den man vom CCC nach all den Jahren äh einfach erwarten kann und weiß, das kriegen die Leute hin, ne,
Aber dieser Begegnungsaspekt war ja die der das große Sorgenkind und da hatten wir im Prinzip so eine Art Geheimprojekt,
was wir äh lieber nicht groß angekündigt haben, weil eben also nicht konkret angekündigt haben, was es sein würde und wie es,
eben auch nicht klar war, wie geil es werden würde, ne? Also gemäß dem Motto, erst Ei dann guck, äh wo das so ein bisschen, ja, so es wird eine Begegnungsstätte geben, also die,
Ankündigung, so.
Und wir wollen mal versuchen, den Kongress abzubilden, aber viel mehr hast du jetzt irgendwie, wenn du auf Events, CCC gegangen bist, äh nicht gesehen. Und jetzt kannst du ja mal erzählen, Tim, wie da so für dich die,
äh wie dann so diese Welt, wie die so war.
Ja, also aus Gründen die ich nach und noch nachliefern kann, war das für mich vor allem ein äh enormer Flashback und in gewisser Hinsicht hätte ich's wahrscheinlich auch besser wissen müssen.
Vielleicht erstmal beschreiben, was war überhaupt da? Also man hatte natürlich das Vortragsprogramm und so weiter. Das bildet sich letztlich jetzt so auch genauso ab.
Andere Kongresse das auch getan haben, das heißt man kann irgendwie diesen Event anklicken, auf Media CCC DE und dann seht ihr die ganzen Vorträge, die da gelaufen sind, sowohl die im Gesetzen Programmen, im kuratierten Teil, als eben auch das, was auf diesen ganzen.
Nebenbühnen und so weiter äh als Communityprogramm gemacht wurde.
Dazu gab's noch die RC drei World. Und die RC drei World ist etwas, was wenn ich das richtig sehe, eigentlich auch erst so im November.
Angefangen wurde, dass es so entwickelt würde.
Nee, ich glaube früher, aber das ist jetzt äh müsste ich jetzt nochmal da alle Monate relativ gleich sind, kann ich dir nicht genau sagen, ähm aber ich würde.
Ich habe das jetzt, ich habe das jetzt dem Infrastruktur Talk so entnommen.
Na ja, okay, dann weißt du, dass äh.
Gab's da noch erste Schritte äh oder so, aber da hieß es irgendwie so Development fing eigentlich erst so richtig im November an.
Das kann das wiederum kann gut sein, ja.
Ähm wo man sich natürlich denkt so, boah, das ist aber ganz schön knapp. Und äh das war dann wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum dann irgendwie so viel geht. Und da hat sich einfach ein Team gefunden.
Ähm
Software, die glaube ich auch erst in diesem Jahr so richtig aufgeblüht ist, auch wenn sie vielleicht schon etwas länger existiert hat, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau. Äh ich glaube, das Original heißt Work Adventure und das äh ist irgendwie
ausreichend Open Source, das nimmt man sich und baut sich im Prinzip so eine zweidimensionale Welt im Web.
Du hast so Räume und Gänge und kannst irgendwo rumlaufen und es ist halt wie so diese alten 2D Adventure, wie man das noch von alten Homecomputern kennt,
Avatar und läuft halt irgendwie durch die Gegend und sieht alle anderen auch noch mit rumlaufen.
Sieht so aus wie Selder oder so, ne?
Ja, so könnte man's nennen, ja.
Wenn man bei Super Mario von einem Level ins andere geht und auch so eine Draufsicht World hat, ne, wo man dann also, weißt du, wenn.
Genau, aber danach so richtig altschulig achtziger Jahre äh mäßig. Das passt ja dann auch zu diesem Retrodesign, das das also dem Logodesign vom vom Event.
Ja und dann,
liefen halt alle anderen auch rum. Und was halt ein Clue war und das ist wirklich gut gelöst gewesen. Man wurde halt angehalten, Kamera und Mikrofon ähm an den Start zu bringen, was ich ja mittlerweile mit Browsern ganz passabel äh realisieren lässt.
Da muss man dann wahrscheinlich auch erstmal so eine, so eine mentale Hürde nehmen, so nach dem Motto, A wie, was jetzt hier Kamera und so und wen muss ich denn jetzt hier reden, aber es sind ja gewisser gewisser Hinsicht sind jetzt alle durch dieses Jahr wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen Webcam gestellt.
Naja und dann ist das System halt einfach so, du rennst irgendwo, wo du eben mit deinem Avatar durch die Gegend läufst, in andere Leute rein. Kaum, dass du in ihrer unmittelbaren Nähe bist,
entspannt sich auch so ein kleiner Umgebungskreis grafisch, um diese Personen herum,
maximal vier Leute werden dann einfach ad hoc, ohne dass man noch irgendetwas Weiteres tun muss, außer sich dahin zu bewegen. Äh in so eine Videokonferenz geworfen oder Videokonferenz, vielleicht diese das richtige Wort, so mitten im.
Mitten auf dem Bildschirm, wo man eben auf diesen Plan schaut, tauchen dann einfach die äh Videoströme der anderen Personen und man kann halt sofort miteinander reden,
Und es ist dann halt wirklich dann so gewesen, dass es eben extrem diesem ich renne einfach in Gang auf der Veranstaltung in irgendwelche Personen rein Moment, entsprach.
Also das fanden schockierend fand ich das.
Ich fand das, das war äh also als das ganze Ding konzipiert wurde, war das meine größte Sorge, ja, dass dieses ineinander rennen,
total nervig ist und auch so ein bisschen, also als ich das erste Mal in der World war und dann irgendwie so da so ein Dings boingte und du blickst in so ein Gesicht, dachte ich auch so boah so.
Es hat sowas von.
Genau das hat halt so ein Chat-Roulette-Bezüge und du denkst einfach nur so, klicke ich jetzt weiter oder habe ich Angst, dass da dann ein Penis ist oder so, ne, also das
das war am Anfang halt ein bisschen äh ähm
ungewohnt, aber ja, genau, wie du gerade sagtest, so im weiteren Verlauf, äh gewöhnst du dich daran, latscht da durch und sagst auch zum Beispiel, grüße einfach mal im Vorbeigehen, weißt du so,
und gehst weiter äh was äh was ich dann, wo du ja das sind ja so Sachen, wo du und ich sage mal, da entsteht so eine Spontankultur,
und du kannst das vorher nicht.
Wissen, ob das so funktionieren wird, ja. Eine meiner größten Sorgen war zum Beispiel auch, na ja, okay, funktioniert irgendwie mit fünf, zehn, zwanzig Leuten in einem
Bereich, ne, aber was ist denn, wenn da auf einmal halt irgendwie vierzig, hundert oder Tausende sind, ne, was äh wenn die sich die ganze Zeit übern Weg rennen und so, ne, aber,
es hat funktioniert. Das war der Teil, wo ich sagen würde so, das war ähm die Unsicherheit
wie geil das funktionieren würde oder ob also wie viele Leute vielleicht auch nach fünf Minuten da genervt rausgehen und das ganze Ding halt dann irgendwie an Tag drei keine Rolle mehr spielt. Das konnte keiner wirklich vorhersagen
bis auf diejenigen, die diese Welt gestaltet haben. Das war ja der Teil, der mich eigentlich am meisten
noch geflasht hat, denn diese 2D-Welt hat, war nicht nur irgendeine Welt, durch die man läuft, sondern das war von ich weiß nicht, wie vielen Beitragenden eine liebevoll gestaltete.
Ein liebevoll gestaltetes Wunderland eigentlich, ne?
Du hattest irgendwie äh also das geht los mit du gehst in die Lounge, in die Lounge, hat aber erstmal noch zu, ja. Aber wenn sie dann geöffnet wird, kommst du rein, das läuft auch im Hintergrund Musik, nämlich der Stream,
der Lounge, ja
Äh du kannst irgendwie zum Po gehen, du kannst zum Zert gehen, du konntest die einzelnen Semies sehen. Ich hatte irgendwie ähm du konntest da, glaube ich, auch so twink peaks äh Situationen waren danach gebaut.
Aus Räumen. Man muss sagen, also man konnte diese Welt war, man konnte sich,
teilweise, da du dann einfach so bewegender, wenn man dann oben aus, also wenn man nach oben ging, dann ging das, bewegte sich die Kamera quasi mit,
und es gab quasi Stellen, wo man dann in eine weitere Welt fällt. Was dann so lustige Aspekte hatte, wie du siehst, ein kleines Wohnmobil.
In dieses Wohnmobil und bist auf einmal in irgendeiner riesigen neuen Welt, die irgendwie total trippig ist äh, äh in der du dich dann bewegen kannst, ne? Und da war wirklich, also,
die irgendwelche Geheimgänge, versteckte Backstages und dann auch immer so stellen, wenn du da hin gegangen bist,
wo dann also Massenkonferenzen möglich waren, wo du jetzt dann,
ja, nicht mit nicht mehr mit wenigen Personen da zusammenstandest, sondern ich glaube, der war halt so äh irgendwie um die hundert war so der Rekord, glaube ich, ne. Wurde auch
Infrastructure Review gesagt, wo hundert Leute in einem City hängen.
Ja und da wundern so Workshops durchgeführt oder es waren halt einfach solche Lagerfeuer, Treffpunkte und das und gerade diese Örtlichkeiten haben dem Ganzen dann nochmal so einen,
spezielles Feuer gegeben. Also ich habe dann halt, bin dann auch so rumgelaufen, habe versucht, mir irgendwie was anzuschauen. Es war natürlich viel zu groß. Also man,
konnte sich da so drin verlieren. Es war einfach Räume, über Räume, über Räume, über Räume, unglaublich tief verschachtelt und mit tausend lustigen, kleinen Sachen und Features äh versehen
gab dann zum Beispiel auch das Sendezentrum. Da habe ich da natürlich da nochmal hingedackelt und dann
Ja, okay, da sitzen da jetzt auch gleich mal so fünf Leute rum, die ich halt kenne und dann ist man auch gleich so wunderbar kontextualisiert gewesen,
Also wie klar war, okay, da geht's jetzt irgendwie um Podcast, da triffst du dann irgendwie auch die Podcastnasen,
Und wenn du dich da irgendwie ans Lagerfeuer setzt so, dann ist schon klar, was irgendwie grad das Thema ist. Also wie Kongress,
Das das war wirklich das das Merkwürdige, dass ich dann wirklich auf einmal so dieses Ding einstellte, so, ah, okay, da sind viele Leute, die ich kenne, viele Leute, die ich noch nicht kenne.
Es ergeben sich neue Gespräche, man wird irgendwie alle zwei Minuten zu einem anderen Thema angesprochen, Quatsch, fünf Minuten mal drüber. Da sagt man ja tschüss, ich muss jetzt weiter, ja tschüss. Dann ist mal wieder irgendwo anders neues Thema und äh
irgendwann habe ich, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr gemerkt, dass dass ich gar nicht in Leipzig bin. Also es hat sich einfach wirklich genauso angefühlt.
Fand ich wirklich erstaunlich. Ja und ich hätt's eigentlich besser wissen müssen. Das ist das ist das ist eigentlich das Irre, ne?
Also weiß ja, dass ich im Prinzip auch schon mal Teil eines solchen Projekts war, was irgendwie mittlerweile siebenundzwanzig Jahre zurückliegt.
Und wir damals halt ohne Bild.
Ähnliches gebaut haben, was ähnliche Dynamik hatte und das das hat sich jetzt hier äh ah einfach wiedergefunden und das war für mich der totale Flashback in dem Moment.
Jetzt musst du dein Projekt noch kurz erzählen von was ihr damals gebaut habt.
Das ist die Villa und war im Prinzip,
so äh eine ja auch so eine kleine Cyberwelt. Man kann jetzt nicht zwei, also sie war auch zweidimensional, man hat sie bloß nicht gesehen,
oder genau genommen war sie eigentlich sogar dreidimensional, weil es war halt so ein Haus, aber da hat's halt irgendwie auch Räume und konntest halt irgendwie durch die Gegend laufen, nur dass du das alles mit dem Telefon gemacht hast.
War's halt in in dem Moment, wo du in einem Raum warst, konntest du halt mit allen Leuten reden, die in dem Raum war. Bist du aus dem Raum rausgegangen? War, waren die halt wieder weg. Und genau dieses Tür auf, Tür zu, Ding, genau dasselbe hat sich jetzt auch in dieser RC drei Welt,
abgespielt. Und es hatte dann auch so einen ähnlichen,
Suchtfaktor, ja, dass wenn man irgendwie draußen war, er hat immer mal eine Stunde in der realen Welt wieder was zu tun, als man sich dachte, so, ah, jetzt gehe ich aber nochmal rein, wollen wir mal gucken, was,
Guck mal, ob irgendwas geht, so, dann ist es irgendwie auch schon nachts um vier. Natürlich geht dann doch wieder irgendwas, genau wie aufm richtigen Kongress. Und ähm ja, das äh
wirklich erstaunlich und ich finde, das ist äh das hat echt Maßstäbe gesetzt. Also der Kongress,
Ist ja in einer einzigen Form immer das Gleiche für mich.
Er überrascht mich jedes Mal total. Bin jedes Mal maßlos überrascht von irgendetwas, wo ich mir denke so, ey, damit habe ich jetzt echt nicht gerechnet.
Und ähm so war's auch dieses Jahr wieder. Insofern vielen Dank an alle, die die sich da,
eingesetzt haben, die äh auch wenn andere gesagt haben, das wird doch nix oder Trübsal geblasen haben oder versucht haben, einem irgendwelche Stöcker zwischen die Beine zu werfen, die einfach gesagt haben, nee, ich,
da jetzt äh ich glaube jetzt da dran, ich mache das jetzt hier einfach. Mir doch egal, was die anderen Leute sagen. Mir macht halt recht. Wir probieren's zumindest, scheitern kann man immer noch kolossal,
ja? Aber wer wer halt auch nicht das Risiko des Scheiterns auf sich nimmt, der wird auch nix erreichen. Von daher kann ich da nur sagen, ja.
Gemacht. Also das war äh astrein,
die ganze Community hat wieder bewiesen, dass sie eben zu Recht als so kreativ und irre und wahnsinnig gilt und das hat sich eben jetzt hier online mal genauso wieder entfaltet, wie es sich sonst eben auch.
Non-Online entfaltet und in Zukunft läuft's wahrscheinlich auch noch auf so eine Melange aus diesen beiden Dingen hinaus. Das könnte noch ganz heiter werden.
Ja, was ich, also was ich für mich gab's, wie gesagt,
so diese dieser Risikopunkt, okay, funktioniert diese World, ne, also wird die angenommen, haben die Leute da Spaß dran? Oder sagen die
nach äh nach zwanzig Minuten. Ey, ich habe den das ganze Scheißjahr in irgendwelchen Video-Calls gesessen. Ich habe da keinen Bock drauf, ne. Äh das hätte wäre durchaus auch denkbar gewesen. Und der andere Teil, der, denke ich, die der
um denen ich große Sorge hatte. Er war ähm,
Kongress-Camp, das sind Events, die leben von dem, was die Leute dort hinschleppen und beitragen.
Und gerade das in der Online-Konferenz abzubilden.
War so meine persönliche, größte Sorge, dass das nicht klappen würde, ja? Und du siehst auch teilweise, dass eine ähm.
Ja, das äh mitunter Personen, sagen wir mal, mit so einer, also auch nicht mit was anderem gerechnet haben, als irgendeine Frontalbeschallung bei dem Event
ja? Aber was dann da eingebracht wurde, wie sich diese Welt geändert hat, ja, wie dann irgendwie
währenddessen neue Sachen gebaut haben. Irgendwelche Schnitzeljacken da rein. Und hier jetzt haben wir unser Wohnmobil nachgebaut. Und das muss aber jetzt woanders stehen, weil wir sind ja jetzt woanders hingefahren. Und äh dann haben sich eine
so wie wurden quasi die ganze Zeit durch Updates neue äh in diese Welt über,
führt und die hat sich auch noch geändert, ne? Wo dann bist du irgendwie hingegangen, waren auf einmal andere Sachen, ja? Und dann ist ja sowieso, ich meine, Gestaltung ist etwas, was mir.
In der Kreativität, die dabei entsteht, halt persönlich ähm.
Zugänglich ist, ja? Deswegen bin ich auch immer so leicht dafür zu begeistern,
was Leute dann da in dieser Welt bauen, ne? Dass dann weißt du, wie gesagt, dass irgendwie jetzt habe ich leider vergessen, welcher Hacker Space das war oder welches Essambly. Aber dass die gesehen haben, okay, wenn man hier Punkte hat, kann man machen, dass jemand in ein anderes, in eine andere Welt fällt, ja?
Dann haben die quasi gesagt, alles klar, dann bauen wir jetzt ausräumen ein TikTok Spiel. Und zwar jedes Mal, wenn du auf auf ein Feld gegangen bist,
Bist du in einen neuen Raum gefallen, in dem das TikTok Toe dann so aussah, wie der Spielzug, den du gerade gemacht hast? Das heißt, irgendjemand hat sich.
Einfach alle States von TikTok.
Automatisch generiert und dann automatisch da die Verzweigung zwischen macht und hat dann weiß ich nicht wie viele tausend Räume dadurch entstanden sind,
in dieses in in diese Worldsup Mitte und das wurde natürlich ausgerollt und dann sind die Leute da rein, haben diktator gespielt, ja. Also wirklich ein äh,
Also diese diese Kreativität, die da äh sich entfaltet, auch von der Community,
Die finde ich dann jedes Mal so so flashend, ja? Das klar da wird dann irgendwie was gebaut, aber das hört sich jetzt, weißt du, wenn du so irgendwie mit den Leuten,
die das bauen, die dann sagen so, jo, wir machen das so und hier die Welt und dann gibt's ein und da können die Leute committen und du denkst schon so boah ey mal schauen, ob das nicht eine zu hohe Hürde ist halt auch, ne, um,
für die Leute, ja? Und dann nachher kommen,
wenn ihr dann mit irgendwie Leuten spricht, die da mitgemacht haben, sagst du so, ja, woher kannst du denn das mit dem GIT? Ja und dann steht's, ja stand doch da. Stand doch da, hier GIT,
Komit, also geht push, geht alles doch easy, steht doch da. Weißt du so aber die haben das an dem Tag gelernt, ja, weil sie's wollten, weil sie ihren Beitrag leisten wollten und ähm,
dann hörst du noch so Sätze wie, ja voll, praktisch mit diesem Gitter, das könnte ich ja, kann ich jetzt für meine Arbeit auch benutzen und ähm das, das äh das ist ja der Teil, der glaube ich auch diejenigen, die diese Veranstaltung.
In der Orga irgendwie begleiten ähm ja dass da dass das ist, was da tatsächlich zu motiviert, ja, den ganzen Teil zu sehen,
den andere darauf bauen in dem Wunderland, in den Möglichkeiten, die man anderen äh bereitgestellt hat so. Und das äh flasht natürlich total. Also ja, war eine geile Sache. Aber wie gesagt, ich muss auch zugeben, dass glaube ich,
allen zwischendurch auch echt mal die Knie gezittert haben, ob das denn alles so werden würde. Aber ist auch bei jedem
Projekt normal, wenn man sich was vornimmt, was halt vorher niemand geschafft oder gemacht hat, ne?
Ja, allerdings.
Ähm.
Ansonsten, es gab natürlich auch wieder die Frontalbeschallung nicht äh nicht komplett äh außen vor lassen. Es gab ein Programm und dieses Mal äh war natürlich, es war auch mit Herausforderungen natürlich äh,
weil wir uns ja eben muss, darf man ja nicht vergessen, wir waren zu diesem Zeitpunkt, das ist das, was im Moment noch Peak Lockdown
ist in Deutschland. Kann sein, dass wir nächste Woche noch eine kleine Quittung für Weihnachten kriegen und Silvester, dann
aber es sieht vielleicht nicht danach aus, weiß ich nicht genau, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, das war der bisher.
Zeitpunkt des Pandemieverlaufs in Deutschland. So, in denen ist diese Veranstaltung gefallen, ja? Und.
Jetzt ging's halt darum, man konnte ja gar nicht mehr mit den Lockdown Restriktionen. Man konnte jetzt zum Beispiel noch nicht einmal mehr sagen, OK, wir machen 'ne Bühne mit 'nem Publikum von zehn Personen, die in zwei Meter Abstand sitzen
Maske tragen und wenigstens klatschen und Gesichter für die Speakerinnen sind, damit die da reinsprechen können. Selbst solche Minimalideen,
mussten ja vom Tisch, mussten vom Tisch gehen. Das war im Prinzip schon so, das war ja so eine Hoffnung, die wir noch ungefähr hatten. Ja, aber selbst das ging nicht. Ähm.
Trotzdem gab es, ich glaube, insgesamt zwanzig Studios, die in äh in verschiedenen äh deutschsprachigen äh Bereichen eben.
Teilweise komplett virtuell da ein Vortragsprogramm äh bereitgestellt haben mit Heralden äh vom Harolds Team, mit ähm,
teilweise ähm eigenen Kanälen, also ich glaube es gab fünfzehn Community-Kanäle, die irgendwie eigenkuratiertes Programm hatten. Zusätzlich zu dem virtuellen Saal eins und Saal zwei. Ja, da sieht man mal also quasi.
Wir vom Content-Team haben im Prinzip sofort gesagt, okay, lass uns,
dadurch, dass wir diesen Mehraufwand durch das Streaming haben, ne, ist eine Sache eine fertige Bühne da stehen zu haben mit Kameras und deine Speaker eine nach der anderen da drauf zu scheuchen. Ähm,
im Vergleich zu, jetzt werden die alle ferngestreamt, ja und du hast die ganzen technischen Overhead, haben die ein ordentliches Mikrofon, kommen die irgendwo hin, ne? Deswegen haben wir relativ früh gesagt, okay, wir halbieren oder ich glaube sogar,
dritten eigentlich nur das Programm. Wir hatten glaube ich im offiziellen CCC Programm quasi,
lassen wir nicht fünfundvierzig Talks, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Drittel von dem, was wir beim Kongress machen, ne, also beim Kongress haben wir.
Doppelt so viele Seele und die werden länger bespielt so oder mit kürzeren Pausen bespielt wie dem auch sei.
Ähm aber dann gehen halt die Studios hin und sagen, ja, nee, Moment mal, also unsere Leistungsfähigkeit ist eigentlich höher, wir sehen da gar keinen Grund, eine Einschränkung zu machen und machen fünfzehn eigenkuratierte Community Kanäle on top,
wo sie irgendwie eine teilweise aus den eigenen Reihen, teilweise aus dem äh einheitlichen CFP Talks genommen haben und einen eigenen Kanal gemacht haben, ne. Leute, die das teilweise noch nie gemacht haben.
Kleinere Hacker-Spaces, äh auch irgendwie so komplett äh ich sage jetzt mal ähm,
neue Gruppen wie was weiß ich Restrealität, die dann irgendwie sagen, jo wir machen hier,
auch ein Kanal, kein Thema, hier Kamera äh klicken bei uns so, ne? Ähm das war schon mal echt ziemlich geil, koordiniert wurde das alles durch eine Aufnahmeleitung gestreamt vom Wok. Muss man natürlich auch sagen.
Weißt du, von in dieser Größe und Breite hat das nach meiner Kenntnis keine Online-Konferenz,
bisher versucht in diesem Jahr und natürlich gibt es da auch mal Probleme, ja? Sound, mal ist die, das Studio, was irgendwie den
da gerade streamt irgendwie nicht ordentlich angebunden, ja oder bei bei einem besonders auch ein Talk, der sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit hat, wurden dann mal die Folien nicht mitgestreamt, ne. Also da gab es eine Reihe an technischen Problemen, aber da muss man.
Halt sich halt echt vor Augen führen, dass da halt ähm
zum gegebenen Zeitpunkt irgendwie achtzehn Streams gleichzeitig abgefeiert wurden. Und daran gemessen.
War das ähm halt ein mega Streaming-Event und die Fehler dann doch relativ wenige, ja. Ähm persönlich würde ich sagen.
Ja, vielleicht kurz dazu, Streaming klingt dann immer so ein bisschen so, als wäre das so, nur so ein One-Way-Ding gewesen, ne, aber tatsächlich war es ja so, die Speaker waren dann.
Immer auch eine Q and A gemacht oder die meisten haben eine Q and A gemacht.
Genau, wir haben eine Q and A gemacht. Die waren auch immer quasi mit den Heralden nochmal verbunden, das heißt so der Stream, über den man geschickt hat, der war dann
Es war nicht einfach so, ich streame jetzt von hier in alle Richtungen oder über irgend so ein Proxi rüber, sondern da gab's halt dann sozusagen auch noch so eine Vernetzungsstruktur, in der mehrere Leute noch mit eingeklinkt waren, sich in den Audio einklinken konnten, Nachfragen stellen konnten, um dann eben auch dieses Q and A zu moderieren
dann Leute zugeschaltet wurden oder einfach nur Fragen aus dem Chat vorgelesen wurden
und das ähm ja, also der es war so richtig der Versuch oder nicht mal nicht nur der Versuch, sondern was da durchgezogen wurde, war quasi so eine Art, wie soll man denn das nennen? So ein,
ja so eine so eine so eine Studiosituation für mehrere Kanäle auch gleichzeitig.
Ja ich worauf ich hinaus wollte ist wenn du als ähm Speaker.
Also ich habe dieses Jahr, ich weiß nicht, ein paar Vorträge hier in meinem Wohnzimmer gehalten, vorne Kamera, ne? Und das ist echt eine Herausforderung. Und ich würde jetzt mal,
vorsichtig sagen, dass ich äh in Vorträgen ein kleines bisschen Erfahrung habe, ja. Ich habe mich, ich persönlich habe mich aber entschieden, dieses Jahr überhaupt gar keinen Vortrag einzureichen und ich habe auch kein gehalten, ne? Weil mir diese Situation.
So ein bisschen äh,
ja irgendwie äh unangenehm ist. Gleichzeitig haben echt äh also einige Speaker haben, das wäre jetzt auch das, wozu ich persönlich geraten hätte. Die haben einfach vorher aufgezeichnet,
trotzdem noch eine Live gemacht. Das glaube ich war wahrscheinlich die beste Möglichkeit, wenn man die Ressourcen dazu hatte, ja, also sei das durch eine Unterstützung von einem Studio. Einige hatten auch, ne, also was weiß ich, eine Universität, wo wo so ein Streaming,
Setup einfach steht und ihr gerade keiner ist, ne? Ähm bei den wirklichen Live-Vorträgen
Wurde jetzt irgendwie weiße zwei Personen in einem oder eine Person sitzt zu Hause und hält den Vortrag live. Da gab's dann
auch technische Probleme. Äh ich glaube, da haben wir wahrscheinlich eine ganze auch mal technische Probleme. Und ich glaube, da haben wir viel gelernt. Ähm gab da,
ja auch irgendwie, ich glaube, ein oder zwei,
Presseartikel, die sich dann über die Qualität äh äh irgendwie geäußert haben, wo ich mir auch sagen muss so, es ist eben was anderes, wenn hier eine achtzehn Streams gleichzeitig so ungefähr laufen.
Ähm beziehungsweise
Nee, es waren nicht achtzehn gleichzeitig. Ich müsste jetzt nochmal gucken, weil ein Studio, wenn ein Studio im Hauptstream, äh wie auch immer, ja, weit über zehn Streams zeitgleich
ist eben was anderes als 'ne Single Track Konferenz mit Moderator und sechs Speakern in acht Stunden, ja? Da kannst du natürlich, dann hast du alle Ressourcen auf einem Haufen und hier waren
hier hast du halt irgendwie, na,
einzelne technische Probleme, finde ich auch total im normalen Rahmen, ist aber natürlich trotzdem auch an einigen Stellen natürlich ein bisschen schade gewesen. Mein persönliches Fazit wäre
Maßstab war im Peak Lockdown, ja wohl keiner, wo du eigentlich noch nicht mal mehr dich treffen durftest, ja?
Das geilste Online-Event des Jahres abzuliefern und das wurde erreicht. Ja und zwar komplett kostenlos und dafür haben hunderte Freiwillige sich irgendwie echt aufgerieben und allen, die dazu beigetragen hat,
haben äh wirklich Respekt und Anerkennung insbesondere, das wollte ich gerade sagen, auch den Speakern, die da wirklich, sage ich mal, den Fallschirmsprung gemacht haben, einen Vortrag bei sich zu Hause in eine Webcam zu halten, live. Ja, vor einem,
nicht allzu knappem Publikum und dann teilweise bei technischen Problemen noch die Ruhe bewahren mussten. Das ist von allen, die dazu beigetragen haben, echt eine enorme Leistung.
Und äh ja, dabei gehen äh immer auch Dinge schief, aber ehrlich gesagt, das tun sie bei jedem CCC Event und das geht eben auch bei jedem CCC Event eben am Ende unter, weil die.
Das Gesamterlebnis halt total überwiegt und das ist auch hier so. Also eigentlich alles, alles wie immer. Aber ich möchte auch betonen so, ich hoffe, dass wir das nie wieder machen müssen.
Und dass wir, ja, müssen, ja? Und dass wir aber den Teil ausbauen, den wir ausbauen wollen. Du hast ja gerade schon auch die Vermutung geäußert, dass das gut sein kann, dass diese.
Art der das Dinge, die dort neu entstanden sind,
bei zukünftigen äh Live- oder Online-Events des CCC ähm ja,
Wie nennt man, wie sagt man das? Weiterleben werden, weiterleben könnten, ne? Kommt ja immer darauf an, ob's jemand macht, aber ist schon relativ wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das war jetzt einfach viel zu erfolgreich und viel zu gut, als dass das irgendwie äh verschwinden würde. Und äh es kann ja auch wenig Hoffnung äh machen. Das wird sich wahrscheinlich schon Ostern,
nochmal wiederholen müssen, weil ich's noch nicht sehe, dass äh der traditionelle Easter Hack
so stattfinden können wird. Es ist klar, steht noch so ein bisschen in Sternen, aber ich werde aber nicht so optimistisch.
Also ja gut das mag sein und ich hab das auch in an einer Stelle gesagt dass ich,
irgendwie in so einem, in so einer Pause würde ich mal kurz interviewt, da habe ich auch gesagt, ich hoffe, dass wir das nie wieder machen müssen. Das wurde dann von einigen verstanden, als eine Kritik an der Veranstaltung. Das ist eine Kritik an dieser Scheiß-Pandemie, Leute. So.
Ähm ne? Ich mache Sachen insgesamt lieber äh freiwillig ist es schön, ähm wenn wenn auch in der Not.
Oder auch in der Not immer noch so ein großer Raum für Kreativität,
und Begegnung und Neues und Austausch geschaffen wird, ja? Muss man auch mal sagen, also überleg mal, welches Risiko diejenigen eingegangen sind, die gesagt haben, okay, wir wir ziehen diese Veranstaltung hoch, ja?
Du hast im Prinzip, ne, du hättest.
X Bauchlandungen mit allem dort machen können. Du es hätte auch sein können zu dem Zeitpunkt, als der die Entscheidung gefallen ist, dass das gerockt wird, dass sage ich mal,
kommerzielle Anbieter, die ja auch gezwungen waren, ja, für diese Onlinekonferenz, Konzepte, Lösungen zu bauen, die auch mitunter ganz gut funktionieren, ne.
Wenn du mal bei ja Bezahl Konferenzen oder so bist wo dann auch ja Begegnungsräume
geschaffen werden und so. Ja, ist nicht so, als hätte die Wirtschaft in dem Bereich vollständig geschlafen und es hätte ja auch, also stand das Risiko im Raum, dass irgendein kommerzieller Anbieter,
bis Ende des Jahres ein Maßstab setzt, den auf einmal,
Ja, diese Veranstaltung nicht erfüllen kann, ja? Und dann werden wir auf einmal nicht mehr die Geilsten gewesen. Das Risiko muss du das Risiko war real. Ja, und das ist sehr schön. Es ist sehr schön, dass das.
Schön, dass wir noch die Geilsten sind, ja?
Damit ich ja beruhigt.
So, also vielen Dank an alle, die sich da in irgendeiner Form eingebracht haben. Und wenn man so einen Nachklapp macht und dann
das vergisst man immer tausend Aspekte, die einen noch geflasht haben und vielleicht einige erzählt man auch nicht, weil das ein bisschen zu persönlich ist, was man da irgendwie, was das persönliche Highlight war.
Und allein, dass es hier persönliche äh Momente gab, äh,
ist das Irre, deswegen möchte ich echt nochmal allen danken, die sich da in egal welcher äh Form eingebracht haben, sei das als Studio, als Kanal, als Speakerin, als Pixelerin, Pixeln ist ja die das Verb für,
teils bauen, die in der äh Word dann entstehen.
Ach so und genau, das jetzt müssen wir noch ganz kurz unser Intro erklären. Am einunddreißigsten morgens um fünf.
Wie sonst bei einem Kongress, ist halt Ende, beginnt der Abbau und alle haben sich dann zum zum Weltuntergang noch versammelt.
Ja, sehr schön fand.
Inklusive natürlich äh äh Protest,
Ja, also Protest gegen den Weltuntergang. Weißt du das ja, Leute, die sind immer dagegen, ne. Kannst ja auch von ausgehen, ja? Wenn, wenn dann irgendwann der Weltuntergang kommt, hast du auch wieder jemanden, der dagegen ist, ne. Hast du ja jetzt schon mit den ganzen Kretas und so, ja, die sind einfach gegen den Weltuntergang.
Frechheit.
Ging alles, ja? Kannst kommen, womit du willst, sagst du, okay, komm, wir reißen die ganze Scheiße ab, auch wieder dagegen. Ja genau, also inklusive wirklich lebhafter lebhaften Protests gegen den Weltuntergang.
Wurde das wirklich ja wunderschön zelebriert und ich glaube auch, dass das die richtige Entscheidung war ähm.
So wie er das getan hat, ja, dass das die richtige Entscheidung von
den Verantwortlichen oder von den Planern war zu sagen, nee, um fünf ist Feierabend, dann wird die Kacke ausgemacht, die machen wir sonst auch so. Da haben wir ja schon immer so gemacht. Ja, weil das natürlich auch das Event halt in seinem
Ne, dem Event auch ein gemeinsames Ende gibt, an dem dann alle einmal gemeinsam traurig sein können,
Also das da ist schon vieles äh vielleicht auch teilweise unfreiwillig genau richtig äh oder unbeabsichtigt. Richtig, genau richtig gelaufen.
Denke ich auch. Ja, also war auf jeden Fall äh sehr wichtig, nicht auf so alte Scheiße halt zu hören wie mich zum Beispiel, sondern einfach äh einfach einfach weitermachen und immer das Richtige tun.
Können wir ja mal zum Feedback kommen.
Genau, kommen wir zum Feedback. Wir haben viel Feedback gehabt zu den letzten Sendungen und ähm,
deswegen gehen wir jetzt nur auf zwei, drei Punkte ein, äh insbesondere zur letzten Sendung, haben wir äh sehr viel positives Feedback bekommen.
Ich habe dann auch noch einen Blogpost dazu geschrieben, weil ähm,
Wir ja, es gab ja diesen, diesen Philosophen dabei, Anne Will, der da irgendwie eben insbesondere über Taiwan gesprochen hat. Und ähm.
Wir haben ja in der Sendung durch Katharinen gelernt, dass vieles von dem, was er da behauptet hat, sich jetzt nicht ganz mit der Realität deckt. Und ich habe dann mal noch dem Rest von dem, was er behauptet hat, hinterher recherchiert und habe dann festgestellt, dass er irgendwie über Japan und
Südkorea auch noch Aussagen getroffen hat.
Also habe ich mal so einen kleinen Blogpost geschrieben, wo ich das alles mal gerade rücke, was jetzt so belegbar falsch war. Ähm das hindert natürlich Leuchttürme wie Boris Palmer nicht, äh das weiter zu behaupten,
ja? Und äh es hindert irgendwie auch nicht die bei der Zeit,
Solche, ja, dann wirklich nicht durch die Fakten gedeckten Meinungsbeiträge von Fachfremden abzudrucken, ohne irgendwie die.
Ja, ohne die Realität damit abzugleichen. Ähm mein Blogpost hat dann tatsächlich.
Die Aufmerksamkeit von Anne Will, äh gefunden, die ähm,
dann äh so in Aussicht stellte, in Zukunft das gerne auch äh nochmal realitätsnah zu beleuchten.
Ähm unter anderem hatte dieser Philosoph dann auch noch behauptet,
Lockdowns seien nicht sehr effektiv, wo du dich so fragst, was denn sonst? Und hat dann noch die, also auch so eine geile geile These, fand ich, Lockdowns treiben das Infektionsgeschehen in die Höhe.
Weil sich die Familien ja dann in ihren Wohnungen gegenseitig anstecken. Und auch so fragst du, ey, also,
Das ist so eine unsinnige Idee, ne. Also wenn du, also das ist wirklich das disqualifizierte ja vollständig, als wenn die Familien sonst nicht zusammen wohnen, ja, also totaler Unsinn. Hat er noch gesagt, ähm,
Ja, also Taiwan hätte eine contact tracing App, haben wir ja festgestellt, hat gar keine. Dann hat er gesagt, in Japan hätten sie eine viel geilere
Japan benutzt exakt das gleiche, Google Apple, Framework wie Deutschland auch, also die haben exakt die gleiche und dann äh hat er sich noch irgendwie über äh Südkorea, fand er jetzt noch irgendwie beispielhaft
und ähm ja Südkorea hat eine schöne zweite Welle,
Ja, also da hat ihnen ihre Datenschutz äh Zentralapp auch nicht großartig geholfen und außerdem hatten sie in ihrer App noch ein Datenleck und wenn also, ja komm, das war alles,
ja, wie dem auch sei, es gab auch.
Du sagst immer so schön Philosoph. Du weißt schon, dass dir auch mal ja ja, aber du weißt auch schon, dass der mal Kulturstaatsminister war in der Regierung Schröder.
Her.
Tatsächlich, nee, wenn ich also wenn ich ehrlich sein soll, ja, muss man sagen.
Ja, jetzt sei doch mal ehrlich, sei doch.
Philosoph wird natürlich äh dem Menschen nicht gerecht, weil er ist Professor, Doktor, Doktor HC und Staatsminister a. D.D.
Und Philosoph. Ja, tja.
Abkürzung kriegst du nicht zusammen. Zumindest nicht vor dem Namen.
Nee. Ich schreibe ja auch immer so lange Texte, die faktenbasiert sind. Da kommst, kriegst du leichter. Kriegst du nicht so leicht ähm,
Titel für. Wie dem auch sei. Also ähm wir haben aber auch äh ja mitunter, sagen wir mal äh negativ Feedback bekommen, weil wir die Idee dieser.
Lockdown-Überwachung über äh das Mobilfunknetz nicht ausreichend kritisiert hätten. Ähm.
Ja, also äh nehme ich gerne hin. Ich denke, wir haben uns in anderen Folgen ausreichend oft gegen jegliche Form von Standortüberwachung äh geäußert. Ähm.
Denke allerdings auch, also ich persönlich, weißt du, was ich persönlich glaube, Tim?
Das ist aber nur so eine so eine Vermutung, ne? Da habe ich jetzt keinen Beweis für. Oder auch gar keinen Anhaltspunkt. Ehrlich gesagt glaube ich, die machen gar keine äh Mobilfunktionenüberwachung.
Ich glaube, ernst, ich glaube, ich glaube ehrlich, Entschuldigung.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, dass die den Leuten einfach sagen, wir machen das. Weil du hast keine Möglichkeit, das zu prüfen vom Telefon aus, ne. Also du, wenn die dir sagen, dieses Telefon bleibt jetzt ein Ort und Stelle, wir überwachen das jetzt übers Mobilfunknetz,
Tja, also du, ne, weißt ja nicht, das ist ja etwas, was vollständig bei dem Mobilfunknetzanbieter im Backend stattfindet
und was dann wiederum, also es es ist ohne Zweifel technisch möglich, dass sie das machen, ja? Ich glaube nur, dass es wahrscheinlich technisch noch nicht mal notwendig ist,
das zu machen, weil A die Leute glauben's dir ohnehin, B die Leute können's nicht prüfen und C, wenn's die Leute umgehen wollen, lassen sie das Telefon irgendwo liegen,
und außerdem, zumindest, wenn du diese Anordnung, wie's ja hier zu sein scheint,
primär für Einreisende machst, denen du ohnehin die Verpflichtung zum Aufenthalt in einem Hotel ähm gegeben hast und die auch vorher geprüft hast, ja,
kannst du eventuell die ganze Sache einfach dadurch lösen, dass die Leute im Hotel halt die Augen aufhalten? Ja, aber das ist wirklich nur so eine zynische ähm.
Panoptikonidee, ja? Das ist halt reicht, den Leuten zu suggerieren, dass sie jederzeit beobachtet werden können und dann auch unerheblich wird, ob du es tatsächlich machst.
Scheint, zumindest ausreichend gut zu funktionieren, wie man den Corona-Infektionszahlen entnehmen kann.
Also einige Leute äh empfanden dies als eine zu große ähm,
Also als als er eine Überwachungsfantasie und der kann, kann ich auch äh dem dieser Auffassung äh kann ich gut zustimmen, kann ich auch gerne nachvollziehen. Und ähm ja, glücklicherweise haben wir mit unseren Infektionszahlen.
Ähm ohnehin nicht das Problem. Also ich gehe ja auch davon, also das wäre noch ein weiterer Punkt, warum ich glaube, dass das äh potenziell gar nicht tatsächlich überwacht wird, weil.
Die ja ohnehin offensichtlich vernünftiger sind,
so ein so eine Quarantäne-Anordnung als sinnvoll zu verstehen. Genauso wie die Leute dort kulturell so geprägt sind, dass sie halt das Tragen einer Maske,
sinnvoll finden, um andere zu schützen und nicht irgendwie eine eine Diskussion über individuelle Freiheiten vom Zaun brechen, weil sie gebeten werden, irgendwie ähm.
Radius, ihres, ihres Speichels ein bisschen einzuschränken.
Aber da da gab's dann auch äh äh Kommentare zu, die das als eine als eine aus äh als eine Unterjochung durch das System empfinden.
Ja, also aber ich denke auch tatsächlich, also würde jetzt irgendwie eine GPS oder äh Telefonnetz basierte Standortüberwachung auch nur in Quaran bei Quarantäneanordnungen in Deutschland passieren,
würde ich wahrscheinlich mich dagegen aussprechen, ja. Ähm und zwar ziemlich sicher sogar. Muss aber auch dazu sagen.
Dass ich auch schon ähm Leute, von denen ich wusste, dass sie eine Quarantäneanordnung haben,
vom Deutschen Gesundheitsamt in dem Zeitraum beim Joggen gesehen habe. Ja, das heißt äh ist natürlich auch nicht so. Als wäre hier die die einen auf mehr Einsicht.
Keine Engelchen.
Okay, dann hatte ich noch in der vorletzten Sendung den ähm.
Jens Spahn zitiert mit seiner Überlegung, dass diejenigen, die als erstes geimpft werden,
mit dem Einfordern von Privilegien sich zurückhalten sollen aus der gleichen Solidarität, mit der sie als erste geimpft wurden.
Und da hat äh Sandra korrigiert, dass dieses Weltbild nicht von Jens Spahn erfunden wurde, sondern die Position des Ethikrats ist.
Und äh außerdem hatte ich gesagt, dass ich unterstelle, dass Jens Spahn schon darauf geachtet hat, dass er in der Gruppe eins ist, bei dem Impfen, da hattest du mich äh schon korrigiert, dass er das nicht ist, weil er kein Altenpfleger ist? Hat er gar nicht nötig,
bei den Immobilien, die der da regelmäßig,
im im engsten vertrauten Kreis nicht nötig ne klar. Aber Nikos korrigiert,
er müsste eigentlich von der Logik in der Logik der in der allerletzten Gruppe sein, die überhaupt eine Impfung kriegt, weil er die Infektion ja schon durchgemacht hat und daher äh eine Impfung nicht mehr vorrangig benötigt. Also da habe ich,
äh in die in die unsinnige Richtung spekuliert und,
Dann gab es noch ein äh drittes Feedback von Tim. Das hatte uns auch nochmal per E-Mail erreicht. Aber ich äh lese einfach mal ganz kurz die äh Mail von Tim vor, weil ihr das sehr gut erklärt. Es geht dabei um den Fall,
des Polizisten, der nachweislich die Daten an den Computern der Berliner Polizei.
Abgegriffen hat von Menschen, die kurz darauf belästigt wurden von Rechtsradikalen,
und ähm da kommentiert Tim, zum Thema Datenabruf im polizeilichen Datenbanken. Habt ihr einiges vermischt, dass in dem Netzpolitikartikel eigentlich recht detailliert dargestellt wird. Das stimmt. Erstens.
Dargestellten.
Fall, dass dass in dem dargestellten Fall der AfD nahe Polizist die Daten abgerufen hat und dass er dafür keinen sachlichen Grund hatte, wird auch durch die Strafverfolgungsbehörden nicht angezweifelt.
Und deswegen kriegt er auch sein äh äh seine ähm sein Disziplinarverfahren. Zweitens, nur ist der bloße Datenabruf ohne sachdienlichen Grund, halt keine Straftat, sondern nur eine Ordnungswidrigkeit.
Und wie sie der Fall zeigt, ein Verstoß gegen Dienstpflichten, der den Job kosten kann. Und dieses Verfahren läuft auch.
Drittens, sagt Tim, eine Straftat wäre es, wenn der Polizist die Daten weitergegeben.
Oder wenn er sie abgerufen hätte in der Absicht, der Betroffenen zu schaden. Diese beiden Sachen kann man nur vermuten. Der Artikel zeigt einige Indizien auf, die insbesondere für eine Weitergabe sprechen,
nur für eine Anklage und Strafverfolgung müsste ihm das auch Zweifelsfall nachgewiesen werden.
Ähm Dinge, die über eventuell auch naheliegende Vermutungen nicht hinausgehen, kann man nicht anklagen. So, und da hat er recht, das habe ich einfach,
in der Eile, in der ich den Artikel noch schnell vor der Sendung gelesen und versucht habe, zusammenzufassen, äh einfach nicht korrekt wiedergegeben und das ist äh,
richtig und wichtig,
korrigiert. Er sagt auch nochmal Zusammenfassung. Man kann natürlich generell kritisieren, dass nach dem geltenden Recht die bloße Datenabfälle Frage ohne sachlichen Grund nur eine Ordnungswidrigkeit ist,
und man kann hinterfragen, ob es in dem konkreten Fall nicht doch möglich gewesen wäre, ähm dem Polizisten über die Abfrage hinaus auch eine Schädigungsabsicht,
und oder eine Daten Weitergabe nachzuweisen, aber die beiden Kritikpunkte muss man dann auch sauber trennen. Habe ich nicht gemacht,
danke ähm für den Hinweis, Tim. Und äh danke,
an ähm Netzpolitik org, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, war das Ingo, der den Artikel geschrieben hatte, ansonsten.
Äh lobe ich, nächste Mal Ingo nicht und dafür dann jemand anders. So ähm kommen wir endlich.
Etwas weniger als einer Stunde. Zu der Hauptnachricht des Tages.
Fast 'ne gute Nachricht ist.
Fast eine gute Nachricht. Ja, also wir hatten ihn bei uns zu Gast, Dustin Hoffmann, den äh Prozessbeobachter, die Sendung mit ihm verlinken wir nochmal in den Shownots, genauso wie seinen,
Vortrag bei der RC drei.
Einige Soundprobleme gab, die den also man kann sich den Vortrag trotzdem noch angucken, aber es an einigen Stellen gibt's ein bisschen Störung, deswegen hat er dann auch den noch ein zweites Mal in Ruhe zu Hause gehalten und auf seinen YouTube-Kanal hochgeladen. Das verlinken wir auch nochmal.
Und ähm wie,
wie wir seitdem wissen, also entweder durch Logbuch Netzpolitik äh durch Netzpolitik oder eben durch die Vorträge, die äh wo ich zumindest einen von sehr empfehlen würde. Ähm,
hat er ähm.
Gab es dann heute die Urteilsverkündung. Und ähm es gab davon nur eine qualitativ schlechte Fernübertragung an interessierte äh Journalisten.
Prozessbeobachter, egal welcher Form war nicht zugelassen, deswegen konnte das denn auch nicht dort sein, ja? Ähm.
Es gab offenbar nur irgendeinen relativ schlechten Stream an ein paar Journalistinnen, die sich auch regelmäßig über irgendwie die schlechte Tonqualität äh beschwert haben. Ähm.
Ich habe das bei den, ja, einschlägigen Leuten, die da offenbar live getwittert haben, heute auch live verfolgt. Und fasse jetzt mal so grob zusammen.
Was die Richterin da ähm,
verlesen hat. Wir verlinken auch das Gesamturteil. Es mag sein, dass ich jetzt vielleicht den einen oder anderen Aspekt auslasse, aber die generelle Stoßrichtung ist, glaube ich, klar. Die Verteidigung hat sich ja.
Primär auf ähm ja ein paar Säulen äh gestützt. Das ist einmal Pressefreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit und dann natürlich noch der Gesundheitszustand.
Und zu dem Thema äh Pressefreiheit hat die Richterin gesagt, dass also er,
Chelsea Hilfe beim Passworts angeboten,
hätte, war mehr als eine übliche journalistische Tätigkeit und ähm.
Das äh da muss man jetzt dazu sagen ähm erstens gibt Gründe, diese dieser Perspektive zu widersprechen und zweitens vor allem hat was es was nicht nachgewiesen ist,
und was wahrscheinlich auch nicht passiert ist, ist, dass er tatsächlich dieses Passwort gecrackt hätte. Ja, er hat nur gesagt, wenn du uns das schicken kannst, können wir mal gucken, ja, aber er hat,
es gibt keinen Beleg dafür, dass das auch passiert,
ist und dass das irgendein Beitrag dazu geleistet hätte, welche Informationen Chelsea Manning extrahiert,
hätte, ja? Sie hat die Information auch ohne diese Admin-Privilegien dort rausbekommen. Äh insofern, dass es nur das Angebot, ja.
Ähm er hat dann auf einer Hackerkonferenz, ich frage mich, welche das wohl gewesen sein könnte.
Dazu dazu aufgerufen, äh man solle der CIA beitreten, um Zugriff zu Geheimnissen zu bekommen und diese äh zu veröffentlichen und potenziell Wiki Leaks zugänglich zu machen.
Ähm und das sei keine äh übliche journalistische.
Tätigkeit. Ja, also damit hätte er quasi den Rahmen des Journalismus verlassen. Jetzt würde ich natürlich sagen, oh krass, das heißt ähm eigentlich ist jede Leaking-Plattform, die ähm Medien anbieten, halt schon.
Also schon eine krasse krasses Risiko, ja. Ich persönlich denke schon, dass ähm eine auch ein Redakteur natürlich eine ähm.
So ein Aufruf
starten kann. Auch der Betreiber einer journalistischen Plattform und ich glaube nicht, dass sich lange suchen müsste, um irgendwelche Editorals zu finden,
in denen Chefredakteure äh großer traditionsreicher Outlets oder Chefredakteurinnen dazu aufrufen ähm,
ihnen ähm irgendwie geheime Informationen über Gesetzesverstöße zukommen zu lassen, ja.
Aber vielleicht nicht unbedingt auffordern, dafür noch extra einen BND einzutreten.
Ja, aber der der macht jetzt den Unterschied auch nicht mehr, ne? Also da äh also das finde ich ne, wir reden hier also.
Okay, ich ich fasse mal nur zusammen. Sie sagt also, damit hat der quasi,
gezeigt, dass er nicht nur Journalist ist, ja? Und deswegen damit das also mit diesen Verstößen gegen was auch immer ein übliches journalistisches Verhalten ist, diskreditiert sie ja letztendlich,
seine ähm seine Bezüge zur Pressefreiheit, ja? Äh hat sie noch sinngemäß so etwas gesagt,
auch die Meinungsfreiheit gibt nicht das Recht, zu diesem,
ausführlich zu diesem, ich hab das jetzt mal irgendwie mitgeschrieben so, also Massen Leaks, ja? Das sei also nicht durch die Meinungs- oder Pressefreiheit gedeckt, dass da so viel
veröffentlicht wurde und sie sie zitierte dann spezifisch, dass äh fünfzig Leute Asyl in den USA suchen mussten.
Weil sie den USA geholfen hatten und in Folge der äh unredigierten Veröffentlichung der in Gefahr waren.
Das Krasse ist aber hier muss man dazu sagen, dass diese Person ja erst identifizierbar waren, nach diesem Guardian League, also wo.
Guardian, das Passwort für die verschlüsselte Datei, äh der der Guardian-Ripp ähm Reporter.
Das Passwort für die verschlüsselte Datei in seinem Buch veröffentlicht hatte, wodurch dann die unredigierten ähm,
in die falschen Hände gelangt sind
Ähm da sagt sie sogar spezifisch, also hat sie den Eindruck erweckt, die Verantwortung für dieses unredigierte, veröffentlichen läge bei Assange, obwohl wir eigentlich wissen, dass das nicht,
der Fall ist. Letztendlich sagt sie, dass Assange in UK keinen Schutz hätte,
Als Journalist und deswegen dieser Schutz als Journalist auch keine Rolle spielen kann für seine Auslieferung an die USA. Das ist das, was sie damit äh was sie dort herbeigeführt hat. Sie betont sogar, dass sie ähm.
An den an das an den Good Fave, äh also an das an das ja, wie soll man das sagen.
An das reine Gewissen ähm oder die guten Absichten der Kläger glaubt und sie sieht keinen Hinweis, dass es sich um ein politisches Verfahren handeln würde oder um Bemühungen, ein Exempel zu statuieren.
Klammer auf, die drohen dem mit hundertfünfundsiebzig Jahren Knast. Klammer zu, ne. Ähm.
Ja, also sie hat sie hat sich schon sehr viel Mühe gegeben. Eigentlich äh nichts wirklich gelten zu lassen.
Gar nichts gelten lassen. Sie sagt auch, das Problem ist, dass er ähm Chelsea Manning nicht nur regelrecht,
animiert und motiviert habe, geheime Daten zu besorgen, sondern sich mit deren
veröffentlichung auch das Recht angemaßt habe, über das Schicksal von Menschen zu entscheiden, über deren Lebensumstände oder Gefährdung er nichts wissen konnte.
All das im Namen der freien Rede. Und das ist aber genau das, was
Also er hat ja spezifisch hatte das ja nicht getan. Also er hat ja genau nicht die Veröffentlichung selber angestrengt. Insofern finde ich das dann schon auch ähm krass, dass dass die Richterin zu einem solch zu einer solchen Einschätzung kommt. Hm dann haben,
war natürlich eine wichtige Säule der Verteidigung, auch die massiven ähm,
Menschen, ja was sind das für Grundrechtsverletzungen durch äh die Überwachung der Botschaft, ja, wo nämlich gesagt wird, ja hier wurde ja gegen,
Also die Informationsbeschaffung durch die Gegenseite hat Grundrechte verletzt. Ja, also die gesamte Überwachung ähm der Botschaft,
ähm die dort stattgefunden hat auf dem Boden Großbritanniens, ja, durch,
Unternehmen UC Global, was, glaube ich, eigentlich seinen Sitz in Spanien hat, wenn ich mich jetzt, wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Und ähm worüber Andi Müller auf dem letzten Kongress auch einen Vortrag
äh gehalten hatte, wo wo man eigentlich weißt du, bei diesen Andy Müller Magun Vorträgen, denkst du dir immer so, äh hat der Typ jetzt ein Rad ab oder ist das alles wahr? Und dann
natürlich ist das alles wahr, ja? Und und du merkst irgendwie so, also irgendjemand anders hat ein Rad ab, ja, aber das, was ähm kommen wir gleich auch nochmal zu was Andi, dieses Jahr, äh bei der RC drei äh vorgetragen hat. Na ja. Ähm
und die Richterin sagt spezifisch ja, für diese Spionage auf dem Boden ähm des Vereinigten Königsreichs,
durch ein Unternehmen aus Spanien im Auftrag der USA
Dafür könnten die USA ja durchaus legitime Gründe gehabt haben und außerdem wird das ja in einem anderen Verfahren behandelt, deswegen muss sie sich damit nicht auseinandersetzen.
Das ist so der Teil, wo du echt sagst, so holy shit, so das das könnte es den USA nicht bringen, ne, diese gesamte äh Fruit of the poisones tree und was nicht alles, ja? Also das ist.
Aber nö, spielt keine Rolle.
Ähm dann gab es natürlich noch diese entscheidende, diesen entscheidenden Aspekt, dass er ja im äh Virginia ähm angehört werden soll, wo irgendwie,
ne, wo hauptsächlich die Fans Leute wohnen. Also da wohnen diese ganzen NSA-CIA-Leute,
und äh die das Argument der Verteidigung war, naja, die Jury wird ja dann dort bestimmt und es ist eigentlich ausgeschlossen, dass der dort ein faires Verfahren äh bekommen würde.
Dem folgt sie nicht, sagt so ungefähr ja aber also ich meine ihr werdet ja wohl Virginia ist ja da ist ja groß genug, der will ja wohl zwölf Leute finden, die ähm die unabhängig genug sind, um darüber zu zu urteilen, also
sie sieht keinen Hinweis, Assange würde kein faires Verfahren bekommen in den USA. Und sie hat also jegliche Form der rechtsstaatlichen,
Verteidigung gegen dieses Auslieferungsersuchen vollkommen abgelehnt. Da ist nicht ein einziges Stück.
Stück Seil gegeben worden, nichts null, ja? Und dann sagt sie so in den letzten fünf Minuten, ja ähm aber okay,
Also der Mann leidet, leidet an Autismus, klinischer Depression und einen eindeutigen Risiko, sich selber zu verletzen ähm oder äh ein Suizid zu begehen.
Und ähm bei den Haftbedingungen in den USA ist es jetzt relativ wahrscheinlich, dass er Special Administrativ bekommt,
und ähm er hat den Intellekt, den die Antisuizidmaßnahmen zu umgehen,
wie es ihm ja hier in den in UK auch schon gelungen ist. Der wurde ja ähm also es wurde ja festgestellt, dass er Suizidvorbereitungen mit einem äh Gegenstand, den er versteckt hatte, getroffen hatte.
Und dann sagt sie, ja ähm deswegen aufgrund dieser Suizidgefahr und der Haftbedingung in den USA können wir den nicht ausliefern, vielen Dank auf Wiedersehen,
Also, was natürlich, also nachdem du, ich hatte das ja, wie gesagt, live da mitgelesen. Wenn du die ganze Zeit hörst, wie jede ein, jedes einzelne,
äh Fragment der Verteidigung irgendwie in der Luft zerrissen wird und dann am Ende irgendwie in drei Minuten liest du ja nee und hier so, nee, es geht nicht, den müssen wir, den können wir nicht ausliefern,
Das ist natürlich schon echt äh krass. Reaktion ist, dass Legalteam von Assanchen möchte, eben natürlich sofort äh die Entlassung aus der britischen Haft auf kurz Kaution beantragen.
Ähm aber die Briten, äh die, die, die, die USA haben natürlich sofort äh Berufung eingelegt gegen,
oder angekündigt gegen dieses Urteil. Ja und jetzt ist halt wird sich, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, am Mittwoch entscheiden, ähm ob sie eine Freilassung auf Kaution jetzt erlauben.
Weil sie haben ja nun mal geurteilt. Ähm und es kann aber gut sein, dass sie dann sagen, na ja, wir haben aber direkt hier schon eine Berufung und deswegen.
Lassen wir dich trotzdem nicht auf Kaution frei. Ich find's aber auch echt spannend. Ja, ich meine, wenn die sagt, so, also sie muss jetzt echt sich Mühe geben, sagen wir mal, die Haftbedingungen in UK irgendwie so rosig zu reden, dass,
dass sie einerseits die Argumentation aufrecht erhalten kann, dass der Mann aus Suizidgefahr nicht in die USA gebracht werden darf, während sie das aber dann offenbar sinnvoll urteilt, dass der mit der gleichen Suizidgefahr in dem Knast bleiben kann, ne.
Ähm insgesamt ist es kein Grund, sich zu freuen, dieses Urteil, weil da viele ähm,
Grundrechte, die eigentlich sehr wichtig sind
in keiner Form auch nur ein bisschen gewürdigt werden, ja? Da ist auch nicht irgendwie so eine sowas wie hier muss man abwägen und irgendwas überwiegt, sondern ihr habt die ganze Zeit gesagt, so, nee, klar, gilt überhaupt nicht. Arschlecken, so, ne? Also, das war wirklich ähm.
Krass so. Ist mein Eindruck und diese Suizid,
äh Gefahr als einziger äh Grund, der nicht expedition ist natürlich auch ein sehr seidener Faden, weil was heißt das denn dann jetzt?
Ne, also heißt das, wenn die Suizidgefahr nicht mehr besteht, äh können wir den ausliefern. Das kommt mir alles sehr äh gefährlich vor. Ähm was ich dann noch ganz lustig fand, ist, dass,
Mexiko. Jetzt politisches Asyl anbieten möchte,
Also das Außenministerium Mexikos ähm soll das entsprechende Prozedere einleiten und die britische Regierung über das Asylangebot informieren, hat ähm.
Oh je. Der mexikanische Präsident Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador ähm,
den irgendwie am Montag erklärt, wo ich mich auch frage so, hm, also der Assange fürchtet sich spezifisch vor der CIA, ja? Und wenn du dir jetzt irgendwie anguckst, was CAA und EA in den letzten,
drei, vier Jahrzehnten.
Unterhalb der südlichen Grenze der USA veranstaltet haben, dann würde ich eine Assance-Stelle äh zumindest so lange nicht nach Mexiko gehen, bis die trompische Mauer äh vollständig steht.
Mexiko ist auch generell grad so ein Land, wo es nicht unbedingt besonders einfach ist, Sicherheitsgarantien zu geben.
Ja ja.
Das ist einfach.
Glaube, das ist ist das nicht sogar das Land, in dem die meisten Morde passieren?
Ist mindestens, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob's jetzt die meisten sind, aber
Mexiko befindet sich gerade in keinem besonders stabilen Zustand. So, da äh werden also viele Leute umgebracht, da ist äh einfach eine eine Menge Kacke am Dampfen, um's mal
galopp zu formulieren. Ähm ich meine, es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass wenn er frei käme, dass er jetzt politisches Asyl bräuchte, weil er ist ja dann sozusagen,
frei und wird dann, soweit ich informiert bin, erstmal so von keinem Land weitergesucht. Schweden hat das ja eingestellt.
Ähm wenn USA dir immer noch haben wollen, ihr Problem, wenn die okay nicht ausliefert, können sie ja nichts anderes machen, als ihn einfach freizulassen.
Also die äh höchste höchsten äh Mordraten in in Städten ähm findest du in Mexiko und Venezuela und Brasilien.
Jeweils über einhundert von einhunderttausend Einwohnerinnen.
Aber es sind nicht nur so Morde, es ist vor allem so ein organisiertes System und äh also wenn du da irgendjemanden schaden willst, dann gibt's da einfach genug,
organisierte Gruppen, die diesen Job gerne übernehmen, äh von daher wäre jetzt Mexiko nicht unbedingt so auf meiner Top Ten für, oh, ich muss jetzt echt unbedingt mal irgendwohin, wo ich mich sicher fühlen kann. Da würde ich dann also so.
Norwegen, ja.
Berlin auch, ja, also so was in der Kategorie, würde ich sagen. Ähm.
Schweden wäre eigentlich auch auf der Liste, ja, aber.
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, für ihn keine Option so. Ähm ich meine, der wird.
Moskau, Moskau, ähm haben wir gute Erfahrungen mit, muss man sagen.
Wenn er jetzt, ich meine, mal ehrlich, meine für mich klingt das erstmal wie ein Armutszeugnis für die Amerikaner, äh für das äh britische Rechtssystem.
Rock Gong äh twitterte dazu heute so sinngemäß du weißt, dass dein äh äh,
Gefangenensystem irgendwie echt ohne Standard ist, wenn die Leute mit den Schauprozessen in den Glaskäfigen äh ihre Gefangenen dir nicht mehr ausliefern, ne, weil.
Ne? Du musst wirklich.
Das muss darf man sich ja nicht, darf man ja nicht vergessen, ja. Das ist ja auch etwas, was das denn uns hier erzählt hatte, ne? Das sowohl Verteidigung
als auch Anklage gesagt haben, ja, von mir aus kann der Asance auch vorne auf die Bank, dass der wenigstens mit seinen Anwältinnen sprechen kann
ja? Und die Richterin gesagt hat, nee, nee, nee, der bleibt schön,
der bleibt schön hinter seinen Anwälte sitzen. In diesem Glaskäfig und wenn der was von seinen Ligeteamen möchte, dann muss der winken und dann müssen die Leute auf der Besuchertribüne zurückwinken, bis das die Baristas und Celisitors gesehen haben und dann kann ja einer zu dem gehen
und äh mit dem Quatschen, ja? Also Leute, die so ein Konzept gegen,
Anklage und Verteidigung durchsetzen, ja? Die sagen, oh, in USA Knast, da musste, uh, da wäre aber vorsichtig, also da würde ich eher sagen, nee, nee, nee, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das geht, ne.
Ja, also UK ist grade, was auch ihr Verhältnis zu Menschenrechten betrifft, in den letzten Jahren, extrem äh unsabil geworden. So, ich meine, wir wollen dann irgendwie auch aus dem.
Gericht für Menschenrechte äh nicht mehr sollen nicht mehr zuständig sein und Menschenrechte finden sie gerade irgendwie total scheiße, weil das stellt ja alles nur beim Brexit.
Theoretisch ist ja das juristische System auch dort äh unabhängig, aber so richtig danach schmecken tut's nicht. Ja, in gewisser Hinsicht.
Wenn ich das jetzt mal.
Fies ausdrücken soll, ist so dieses also wir wollen uns hier nicht unser Recht wegnehmen lassen, alle Journalisten, für alles, was sie schreiben, einfach mal in Knast stecken zu können,
Aber wir wollen uns jetzt auch grade mal hier nicht an die Backe kleben lassen, dass wir dem Trump jetzt hier noch irgendwie seinen letzten Todeskandidaten ausgeliefert haben.
Ja, äh das äh funktioniert jetzt irgendwie überhaupt nicht und überhaupt stehen wir damit äh relativ schlecht da und wir wollen wir wollen das jetzt eigentlich nur noch von der
wollen es jetzt nur noch loswerden das Thema und deswegen nehmen wir ja so, oh ja, also du siehst ja echt ganz schön gefoltert aus so hier, wie kommt das nur?
So können wir so körperlich ja jetzt nicht auf Reisen schicken, da lassen wir dich mal frei.
Ja. Also ich ich man darf ja einen Aspekt nicht vergessen, den äh äh das uns ja auch erklärt hatte, die Richterin dort. Ähm das ist ein verhältnismäßig niedriges Gericht.
Was eben normalerweise.
Ja, man könnte sagen, so eine grobe administrative Prüfung äh in den Fällen macht, wo es Auslieferungsabkommen gibt, ne, wo dann irgendwie,
ja eine formale Prüfung des Antrages äh,
dahingehend gemacht wird, so aha, ne? Du du wirst gesucht wegen, ich sage jetzt mal Mordes, die USA hätten dich gerne, Mord ist bei uns auch strafbar. Ähm,
und deswegen ist das, was dir hier vorgeworfen wird.
Auch nach unseren Maßstäben vertretbar und deswegen geben wir dich in guten Vertrauen in die Hände der USA, dass sie das dort mit der gleichen Qualität behandeln wie wir, ja? Wenn das etwas ist, was bei,
uns nicht strafbar ist, dann machen wir das nicht,
und wenn ja, wenn das ein Land ist, wo wir A gezweifelt daran haben, dass du ein rechtsstaatliches Verfahren oder eine angemessene äh Behandlung bekommst, dann machen wir's auch nicht, ne? Das ist letztendlich ein so eine,
eine eine relativ langweilige Fleißaufgabe. So und die ist jetzt natürlich mit einem Fall von internationaler, diplomatischer Tragweite da beschäftigt. Ja und.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass dieses Urteil ihr Weg ist, am Ende, wenn.
Vielleicht doch höhere Gerichte, dass alles nochmal kassieren und ihn ausliefern
Auf der richtigen Seite der Geschichte gestanden zu haben. Ja, weil ähm ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass äh Studien Assange bei einer Auslieferung an die USA noch lange lebt.
So und das spiegelt sich ja hier in diesem Urteil wider. Und insofern kann ich schon würde ich vermuten, dass eine komplett dahergeholte ähm Interpretation, ja, dass sie halt sagt, okay ähm.
Das ist die die beste Möglichkeit hier ähm meinen Kopf wenigstens aus aus der,
Schlinge des des historischen Urteils zu ziehen und trotzdem ja letztendlich 'ne relativ einfache irgendwann später den höheren Gerichten zu ermöglichen.
Sehr zynisch, ja, aber ähm mutig war das Urteil nicht.
Nee, das kann man nicht sagen. Aber es ist, wie es ist und ähm ich gehe jetzt auch mal davon aus, also diese Berufung macht's dasselbe Gericht oder macht das ein höheres Gericht?
Nee, Berufung geht ja dann immer an höhere Gerichte.
Ja, das heißt, damit ist sie die Sache jetzt schon los.
Ja, sie muss jetzt ja noch über diese Bailey Geschichte urteilen. Das macht, glaube ich, noch sie und dann geht das an ein äh höheres Gericht. Ja, also das äh.
Mhm. Damit ist eigentlich erstmal alles wieder offen.
Ja, das hatte ja äh ähm hatte das Sinn uns ja auch schon gesagt, ja, der also letztendlich ja, ähm.
Wer das Urteil andersrum ausgegangen wäre es jetzt genauso, ne, würde auch in Berufung gehen, also beide Seiten hatten ja schon gesagt, wir kämpfen hier ähm bis aufs Letzte.
Und ähm das ist ähm relativ klar, dass das eben auch passieren wird, ja.
Und äh da ja,
Also dass das wird jetzt äh sicherlich noch äh lange so weitergehen. Ich denke aber trotzdem, dass äh auch das also ich denke, es ist eine Fehleinschätzung, dass das, was Julian Assange getan hat, kein,
investigativer Journalismus war.
Ganz klar mit den Outlets zusammengearbeitet. Er hat ganz klar äh hat Wiki Leak sich da sehr um die äh um das Religieren der äh Inhalte bemüht. Ähm es gab damals, das weiß ich, eine massenhafte Diskussion, um.
Diese oder äh eine eine starke Diskussion, um ne, sind Massen Leaks jetzt irgendwie sinnvoll oder nicht, ne? Oder ist es sinnvoll ähm,
Ja, das irgendwie äh redigiert durch andere,
Auszugsweise zu veröffentlichen. Ich denke, dass eine entscheidende Lehre war, aus dieser ganzen Angelegenheit, dass das auch vom politischen Effekt her sinnvoller ist,
zu verzichten? Also wir hätten nicht so lange äh aus den Snowden Veröffentlichungen gelernt und diese diskutiert, wenn die einfach einmal alles auf einmal rausgehauen hätten.
Und ähm.
Also so rein von dem von dem Impact her, ne? Und wenn du irgendwie Panama, Papers und sonstige Veröffentlichungen anschaust, dann haben die alle diese strategische Lehre daraus gezogen, dass sie ihren Enthüllungen über,
Gesetzesverstöße mehr Gewicht geben, wenn sie die nicht alle auf einmal rausknallen. So, ähm.
Es gibt dann diese diese Sache eben, okay, kommen da Leute unter die Räder mit mit Klarnamen und so weiter, das ist ein Risiko, was da steht, ähm wo aber jetzt es auch,
diese also diese Aussage, dass da fünfzig Personen hätten Asyl beantragen müssen und so, das ist eine Aussage der Ankläger, die natürlich dann sagen, ja den Beweis dafür haben wir nicht, weil damit würden wir ja diese Leute in Gefahr bringen. Also das ist, ne, das
nur sagen, diese Aussage können die leicht tätigen. Nun.
Nun, jetzt werden wir in zwei Wochen schlauer sein, denke ich mal.
Ja, es gibt natürlich auch noch das, also es gibt natürlich noch ein Problem, ne, was was Assange jetzt hat.
Sagen wir mal, gehen wir mal davon aus, die Berufung wird irgendwie abgelehnt und oder äh ne und Assange kommt auf,
Kaution frei, ne? Wird er auf jeden Fall wird ihm gesagt werden, er muss in, in Großbritannien bleiben, um seinem Auslieferungsverfahren,
entgegen zu streben, was ja dann weitergeht in der nächsten Ebene. Hm.
Könnte sich jetzt vorstellen, dass er versucht, dass also wenn er, dass er versuchen könnte, äh die Gelegenheit zur Flucht zu nutzen.
Warte mal, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so ganz. Es gibt doch jetzt das Auslieferungsverfahren von den USA und das von Schweden gibt's nicht mehr. So, das heißt, wenn jetzt diese Berufung abgelehnt wird, dann ist das Ding doch vorbei für ihn.
Geht, der könnte ja in jedem anderen Land sofort wieder ein Auslieferungsverfahren bekommen.
Und von welchem denkst du, könnte er eins bekommen?
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Deutschland da nicht sofort sagen würde, großartig, machen wir mit. Warum sollte Deutschland sich ein Urteil in Großbritannien vom vierten Januar gebunden fühlen?
Ach du meinst, wenn er in einem anderen Land ist, dass er dann nochmal von den USA eins reingedrückt bekommt?
Ja ja klar. Also du müsstest ja, der muss jetzt.
Ja, ja, okay, jetzt kann ich dir.
Nächstes Land kann nur eins, also wenn er irgendwann die Gelegenheit.
Okay, aber äh also er kann auf jeden Fall UK verlassen. Da da müssen wir uns jetzt einig. Das hatte ich jetzt gerade falsch verstanden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er, dass die äh Briten ihn gehen lassen, solange noch ein Verfahren anhängig hängt. Das ist ja klar, dass sie das nicht machen.
Ja gut, aber das ja, aber wenn die Berufung abgelehnt ist.
Wenn das passieren würde, wovon ich nicht ausgehe,
dann dann wäre ein freier Mensch und könnte sich in Großbritannien frei und sicher bewegen, bis die CIA ihm irgendeinen Norwegok äh in Tee gießt oder in die Unterhose schmiert. Und ähm,
Er könnte sich auch wahrscheinlich in vielen anderen Ländern frei bewegen, aber am besten würde er sich eins aussuchen, wo er kein Risiko hat, dass da überhaupt ein ähm Auslieferungsverfahren,
eröffnet werden könnte. Und ich glaube nicht, dass er das in dass er in der Europäischen Union äh diese ähm diese Gelegenheit hätte.
Also doch Norwegen.
Ey du, Mann, der also der,
es wird eng für ihn, ne? Also vielleicht äh setzt er sich ja mit mit Edward Snowden in in Moskau zur zur Ruhe oder auch eine eine,
eine Sache, die nicht ausgeschlossen ist, ja, aber jetzt auch so sehr, sehr weit und sehr spekulativ hergeholt.
Obama Administration hat damals spezifisch.
So sagt man, nicht das Verfahren gegen Assange eröffnet, weil sie diese Diskussion um Pressefreiheit vermeiden wollten,
und es wird nachgesagt, das sei erst durch Trump aufgemacht worden. So, das ist aber irgendwie nun, das ist irgendwie Hören, sagen,
jetzt gibt's zwei Möglichkeiten. Trump hat gerade eh Bock äh irgendwie in jede Kanne zu pissen, die ihm einer hinhält,
und vielleicht sagt er einfach so und übrigens wisst ihr wat? Ähm,
Ich begnadige noch eben den Assange. Das kann er ja jederzeit machen bis zum neunzehnten Januar hat er dafür Zeit. Zwanzigsten ist er ja raus.
Das könnte der machen, einige glauben dafür müsste Assange erstmal in die USA kommen oder so, nee völlig, völlig unerheblich, der kann den Assange jederzeit begnadigen. So könnte sein, dass irgendjemand es schafft, den Trump davon zu überzeugen, kann aber auch sein
der beiden das machen würde, weil als erste Amtshandlung halte ich für enorm unwahrscheinlich, weil Biden ja im Prinzip die Administration als,
Vizepräsident vertreten hat, die den gesamten Schaden durch Assange hatte. Insofern wird der nicht besonders motiviert sein. Ähm ausgerechnet den zu begnadigen.
Und Biden wahrscheinlich mit dieser ganzen äh Trump-Präsidentschaft einfach unzufrieden ist
ja? Und die Rolle von Julian Assange äh hinsichtlich der Clinton E-Mails und so ja in diesem Kontext auch ähm bei einigen Leuten zu Verstimmungen geführt hat. Insofern halte ich das für äußerst unwahrscheinlich, dass Beiden das machen,
würde, aber theoretisch könnte er. Brauch er nicht seine Begleitung. Er ist am Ende seiner Amtszeit auszusprechen, kann er jederzeit.
Ja, ich glaube, das würde er nicht tun. Also und unter anderem wegen wegen der also die Gründe, die du genannt hast, die,
könnten alle so hinhauen, aber ich denke, er wird vor allem auch erstmal darauf bedacht sein, sich zu Beginn seiner Präsidentschaft nicht sofort wieder.
Dem juristischen System voranzustellen, wie,
Trump das jetzt die ganze Zeit gemacht hat. Deswegen fallen, glaube ich, Begnadigung erstmal äh aus. Er muss nicht irgendwie anstrengen,
und weiterverfolgen, da gibt's ja auch noch andere Möglichkeiten. Ähm von daher ja,
ob Trump das macht, weiß ich nicht, weil die Frage ist ja eher, hat Trump was davon?
Also das ist ja sozusagen für ihn, ist ja dem geht's ja nicht um Recht und Gesetz oder um irgendwie Ehre oder irgendwas, sondern er geht ja nur davon, hat er einen Vorteil davon, Assange.
Äh zu begnadigen. Bringt ihm das.
Ja, da muss man jetzt einfach mal in die Gruppen gucken und ähm gucken, ob ob das, ob er damit irgendwie den und Leuten eine Freude macht.
Du weißt, man müsste einfach nur das passende Gerücht äh starten sozusagen auf Kuana.
Julian Assange ist äh oh man, da da reicht jetzt leider meine Fantasie nicht aus, mir sowas ausreichend Beklopptes einfallen zu lassen, aber irgendwas, was ihn davon überzeugt, dass er dadurch der Geilste bleibt.
Es ist es ist wichtig, der Geilste zu bleiben.
Absolut.
Okay, kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Also ähm um das nur
wir haben jetzt hier, ich habe jetzt ja hier Richtung Ende noch ein bisschen spekuliert. Ich würde nochmal äh betonen, das Fazit von Dustin bei uns in der Sendung auch im Vortrag war, das geht noch lange so weiter und das sagen auch äh andere Gelehrte, die diese Sache beobachtet haben. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
der wahrscheinliche Pfad ist, dass die Berufung.
Zugelassen wird, dass er damit, dass es damit nochmal irgendwie zu jahrelang hin und her geht und dass er potenziell natürlich sollte jetzt die Berufung ähm.
Anders entscheiden, dass es dann natürlich noch den äh eine Art gibt. Das heißt, er hätte noch mindestens noch mindestens zwei Gerichte, äh die auf die mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit noch zu,
zur Verfügung stünden, um diesen Fall zu verhandeln. Aber ich kenne mich leider nicht mit den genauen Regularien des britischen ähm,
rechts und Berufungssystem aus, aber dass das irgendwie jetzt zeitnah erledigt ist, ist die unwahrscheinliche Variante.
Aber es ist durchaus möglich, dass er erstmal auf Kaution frei kommt. Das ist äh nicht nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich, oder?
Halte ich auch für unwahrscheinlich, aber es werden natürlich äh wäre natürlich super. Und ich gehe davon aus, dass der dann also.
Steht gleich vor der nächsten Botschaft.
Also ich meine, man muss halt eine Kaution wird ja so eine Kaution wird ja so festgelegt, dass sie quasi die die Flucht.
Ne, die Flucht maximal unattraktiv macht und ausschließt,
insofern gehe ich davon aus, dass sie in diesem Fall enorm hoch wäre diese Kaution und gleichzeitig sich viele finden würden, egal welchen Kautionsbetrag aufzubringen.
Und sich genug Leute finden würden, die sagen, ist auch nicht so schlimm, wenn ich das Geld nicht wieder sehe.
Und das wiederum treibt natürlich diesen Preis in die Höhe. Also kann gut sein, dass sie halt dann sagen, jo, du wirst gegen eine halbe Milliarde Kaution lassen, weil ich gehen und dann kommt die halt nicht zusammen und dann muss er halt weiter da sitzen bleiben oder so. Ich du, ich spekuliere da,
wir lassen's mal auf uns zukommen. So, eine der großen äh Sorgen,
ähm bei den ganzen digitalen Contact Tracing Verfahren der Zentralen Genese, ist ja das ähm.
Die Polizei diese Daten nutzen könnte. Und es gibt ja äh wie wir eingangs auch erfahren haben oder nochmal wiederholt haben, auch relativ wenige Länder, die eine zentrale, eine zentrale Contact Tracing App haben.
Ähm es gibt aber eine in
Singapur. Ich warte auch gar nicht, mir war gar nicht mehr so klar, dass die äh tatsächlich die meistverbreitete ist prozentual. Verbreitet er als die deutsche Corona-App? Wollen wir irgendwie mit zwanzig, fünfundzwanzig Prozent äh Verbreitung
rechnen und die Singapurianische App sei, so lese ich von fast achtzig Prozent der Population Singapurs,
äh in Nutzung. Population Singapur ist fünf Komma sieben Millionen. Ähm.
Wobei, ich glaube, das muss aber auch die weitere Metropolital äh Metropolitan Area sein, aber ist ja klar, ist ja ein Stadtstaat mit ein bisschen mehr drum rum. Und äh jetzt hat der ähm.
Der Herr gesagt, ja, also die singaporeanische,
Polizei äh darf, auf alle Daten zuzugreifen, zuzugreifen, inklusive den Daten von dieser Trace together App,
im Rahmen von Strafverfolgung.
Ja und da haben natürlich jetzt auch einige gesagt, seht ihr, deswegen hat der CCC sich die ganze Zeit für
dezentrales Contact Tracing eingesetzt, ja? Stimmt. Allerdings, ne? War das jetzt auch nicht so schwer vorherzusagen, weil
zeigen natürlich alle wieder auf Singapur und sagen, ah hier, guck mal, Polizei und so, ne, aber in Deutschland haben wir doch auch in mehreren Bundesländern sofort die Zugriffe auf das
Papier und Bleistift äh tracing in den Restaurants gehabt, was dazu geführt hat, dass halt irgendwie am Ende nachher die Hälfte der Leute bei dem Scheiß auch nicht mehr mitgespielt haben, ne. Also äh enorm,
Es ist unverständlich und dumm, eine solche Aussage zu treffen, wobei man jetzt sagen muss, in Singapur,
ist das wahrscheinlich tatsächlich kein großes Problem, diese Aussage zu machen, weil ähm in Singapur ungefähr alles unter Strafe steht, drakonischen Strafen und die das auch total geil finden.
Ja, das also ich Singapur, egal was, gehst du an irgendein gehst an irgendeinen schönen Teich, freust dich über das Wasser, ist da ein Schild, was da alles nicht machen darf,
mit irgendwelchen äh hohen Strafen immer so im im,
im im enorm übertrieben und schmerzhaften Bereich, so in der in der Bahn trinken sofort irgendwie gewisse Vermögen los und also alles äh,
Die haben da so ein so ein Straffetisch, ja. Haben auch mitunter sehr komische ähm,
die sie dann noch verhängen können, die zu den europäischen Maßstäbe nicht vertretbar sind. Und äh das Einzige, was ich sehr schön fand, war ähm ähm in Singapur, also ne, U-Bahn, Strafen, Strafen, Strafen?
Und bei einer Sache steht einfach nur dran, darfst du nicht machen. Da steht noch nicht mal eine Strafe dabei. Das ist Durian mit in den Zug nehmen.
Steht kein Betrag daneben, da steht einfach nur No Duria.
Ist das diese Frucht, die so stinkt?
Ist äh eine ja äh Delikatesse, so eine Frucht und ähm die riecht äh sehr stark.
Und zwar ähm könnte man den Geruch am ehesten vergleichen mit ähm Erbrochenem. Und die macht eigentlich jeden Innenraum, in dem so eine Frucht anwesend ist für längere Zeit äh unbenutzbar.
Warum warum isst man das.
Äh ja, also das schmeckt tatsächlich auch ganz gut.
Aber es riecht halt relativ stark, ja? Und die also kannst du höchstens so komplett stark eingeschweißt kaufen ähm oder sehr viel an so ja Streetfood-Ständen oder so.
Genau und aber das ist, das ist offenbar so. Das ist das also das ist
ich fand das nur amüsant, weil da halt diese ganzen Strafen stehen, ne? Kaugummi, kauen, äh getränkt, trinken, essen, alles, alles, eine so eine lange Liste. Und immer direkt daneben die die Strafe. Und dann einfach nur
norian. Das finde ich so.
Hast du verstanden, was die Motivation hinter dieser Regel ist? Ich meine, das ist, jeder versteht, dass es eigentlich zu geil schmeckt, als dass man's wirklich bestrafen könnte?
Nee, die also nein, es es ist wirklich nicht möglich, dass du so ein Ding mit in einen Zug nimmst. Es gibt, ich hab's jetzt auch grade nochmal gesucht, also du findest auch ähm Schilder, wo wo dann eine Strafe dabei ist,
Singapur Dollar. Also wenn das jetzt ein Schild aus Singapur ist. Nee, ne Durian.
Hier doch, ich habe ein schönes Schild. So, genau, also äh ähm.
Rauchen, eintausend Singapur Dollar, essen und trinken fünfhundert, irgendwas brennbares mitführen, fünftausend und dann notorieren's.
Na ja, okay, also Duri, keine Dorian mit in Zug nehmen, darfst du nicht machen. Machst du aber eigentlich auch, dass äh machst du von alleine nicht, weil die meisten Leute sich so ein Ding noch nicht mal hm.
Untern Arm klemmen würden.
Da gibt's bestimmt bald eine Bewegung gegen Dorian muss auch in der Öffentlichkeit meine Freiheit essen zu dürfen ja und es muss.
Na du müsstest in Deutschland auf jeden Fall und zwar ohne ohne Artenschutz. Maskenverbot.
Oh Mann e.
Okay. So, dann haben wir ähm.
Werden ja nicht ähm müde über äh die Menschenrechtsverletzungen im Bereich der Staatstrojaner zu sprechen. Äh vor allem weil das Citizen Lab da ja ähm,
wieder mal eine Veröffentlichung nach der anderen. Zu hart gerade, also habe fast im Monatsrhythmus den Eindruck, also sie scheinen gerade gute mh.
Einerseits gute Kontakte zu Zielpersonen und andererseits gute Signaturen zum Entdecken äh von äh NSO.
Pegasus zu haben
und haben jetzt wieder einen Report, wo sie sagen, im Juli und August zwanzig zwanzig äh wurde also Pegasus, diese Schadsoftware der NSO Group äh auf sechsunddreißig persönliche Telefone,
von Journalisten äh und anderen im News-Bereich tätigen Angestellten von Al-Jasira,
eingesetzt und ebenfalls das Telefon eines Journalisten in London,
oder des des Londoner Senders al-Arabi TV. Ähm.
Da wird beschrieben, mit welchem das gemacht wurde äh gegen iOS äh dreizehn fünf eins und konnte zu dem Zeitpunkt auch das neueste iPhone elf äh damit hacken.
Und äh sie ähm gehen davon aus, dass das äh.
Sowohl ähm auf Saudi-Arabien als auch die Vereinigten,
Arabischen Emirate zurückgeführt werden kann. Ähm die anderen einige an einige andere dieser Journalistinnen waren zu dem Zeitpunkt, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
In Katar und die Infrastruktur, die dabei genutzt wurde, also ne, wenn man jetzt so eine Schadsoftware aufm Telefon anbringt, die muss ja irgendwo auch,
entweder also erstmal bereitgestellt werden, dann muss sie ihre Daten irgendwo hinsetzen, sagen sie die Infrastruktur, die für diese Angriffe genutzt wurde, äh bestand aus Servern in Deutschland, Frankreich,
Königreichs, Italien und hat äh verschiedene Cloud Provider,
genutzt, ja? Und sie haben das auch an Apple gemeldet. Warum erzählen wir das immer nur, weil das natürlich eine weitere äh,
Liste ist von diesen eben ja menschenrechtswidrigen und grundrechtswidrigen Einsätzen dieses Unternehmens ähm,
gegen hier wieder,
ja Journalistinnen in Regimen äh oder im Auftrag und im Interesse von Staaten, die nun wirklich keine äh demokratischen
Prinzipien haben. Und das ist deswegen wichtig, weil die NSO Group würde ich sagen, der einzige.
Täusch ich mich da jetzt, ja aber sagen wir mal der einzigen äh nennenswerte ähm,
Wettbewerber ist von Finn Fischer, ähm gegen die, ja, in Deutschland dieses ähm Verfahren.
Wegen Umgehung der Exportrestriktionen läuft und,
kann natürlich nur hoffen, dass ähm solche Forschungen eben auch,
zu einem Vorgehen gegen die NSU-Group in Israel führt. Allerdings scheint das ja, ist jetzt auch nix Neues, dass ähm.
Ja, die NSO-Group-Produkte, auch bei Staaten eingesetzt werden, die jetzt nicht immer die großen Freunde äh Israels sind. Ähm,
Tja, also wir hoffen mal, dass äh dass auch das irgendeine Form von Sanktionen gegen das Unternehmen ähm hinter sich haben wird.
Zur Folge haben, wird aber die Historie der Entdeckungen ähm,
von NSO Pegasus äh hat da bisher keine äh Konsequenzen gehabt. Und äh die Forschung vom Citizen Lab ist immer eigentlich von besonders hoher Qualität.
Bitter, dass man sowas irgendwie so unter ja mal wieder äh hier nur bespricht.
Ja, aber die Sachen kommen ja immer wieder. So ist es.
Kommt auch gerade noch was anderes äh wieder in den USA. Gibt's ja jetzt wie in Deutschland einerseits um die Wurst und vor allem um den Impfstoff.
Und ähm man hat sich gedacht.
Total super, wenn man da irgendwie total intelligent vorgeht und wie kann man intelligenter vorgehen als äh,
intelligenten Algorithmen. Und so wurde äh die Firma damit beauftragt, auch äh hier einen Algorithmus zu entwickeln, um diese Verteilung des Impfstoffs zu machen.
Alter, die die haben sie, die haben ja auch damals schon Schlange gestanden, das das ist ja schon wieder fast in Vergessenheit geraten. Paar Landje hat natürlich auch damals Schlange gestanden, als es ums contact tracing ging.
Und zwar sowohl irgendwie bei App-basierten Systemen als auch Unterstützung der Gesundheitsämter und so. Da standen die ganz vorne, haben gesagt, ach so, ja, Daten können wir.
Ja, auch äh das Immigrationssystem äh wird von ihnen äh,
geführt, wenn ich das richtig äh sehe, das äh scheint äh auch nicht so richtig gut gelaufen zu sein. Also.
Auf jeden Fall sind auch generell die Erfahrung mit solchen AI-Algorithmen äh nicht besonders gut, wie das ja oft der Fall ist, insbesondere so im medizinischen Bereich. Da gibt's also schon,
äh gab's auch schon vorher Berichte, dass also oft die Algorithmen einfach dazu geführt haben, dass irgendwelche weiße vor nicht weißen gegenüber bevorzugt werden, ja große Überraschungen. Ja und äh,
schön so wenn man so 'ne Intelligenz hat und ich glaub wir hatten diese Diskussion auch schon mal,
glaube ich, im Kontext mit äh Österreich und was war das nochmal Krankenversicherung.
Auch so ein intelligenter Algorithmus äh an an Start geht.
War das in Österreich nicht primär die ähm.
Oder arbeits war das Arbeitsvermittlung, Arbeitsvermittlung war das, ne? Genau, Arbeitsamt, genau. Genau, wo dann auch sozusagen nicht unbedingt äh die richtigen Personen gefunden werden und wo man auch gleich diesen Effekt hat, so
dass die politische Ebene dahinter dann sagt so, naja ist ja nicht unser Fehler, das war ja der Algorithmus, der hier falsch gelegen hat. Ja.
Jetzt muss man natürlich noch sagen, also ist äh ja so ungefähr die.
Es ist schon so so edel, wie's nur werden kann, ja, die die machen eigentlich keine äh keine ethisch.
Respektablen Projekte. Es ist auch erklärtes Ziel dieses Unternehmens so. Ähm.
Das gehört Peter Thiel, das ist der der böse Zwilling von Elon Musk, ne, könnte man sagen. Die haben doch äh beide sind, glaube ich, ähm.
Ja genau.
Hat, der Facebook hat ja mit äh angestartet.
Das war aber als Investor, ne? Weil ich glaub die Kohle hatte der wie Elon Musk ursprünglich aus PayPal. Und seitdem.
Rennt der Peter Thiel jetzt als Investor da durch die USA und äh jetzt werden die äh Freundinnen des Herrn der Ringe,
auch den Namen etwas sagen. Ich persönlich bin ja nicht so der Tolkien,
das Lexikon, aber die sieben palantieri sind die weit Sehenden, auch als die sehenden Steine oder die sieben Steine bekannt und ähm.
Sie äh befinden sich dann Mittelehre und zeigten weit in Raum und zeitentfernte Szenen. Hatten aber auch untereinander Verbindung, sodass sie auch eine Kommunikation über große Entfernungen möglich machen,
ja, also Einblick in in weit, in Raum und Zeitentfernte,
Szenen. Mit ihrer Hilfe regierten die Herrscher die beiden Großen von ELENDIL in Mittelerde gegründeten Königreiche Arnor und Gondor.
So, nach den Dingern benennst du dein Unternehmen, ja? Dann weißt du auch echt, was da los ist. Und ähm ja, ähm ne, der Missbrauch ist äh das Geschäftsmodell.
Und ähm.
Ja, dass äh die also Palanthi ist so die Big Data Bude eigentlich, ne? Die die sagen immer, gibt uns die Daten, äh wir werfen da genug Computer drauf, dass da irgendetwas rauskommt.
Ähm was ihr haben wollt, ist jetzt egal in welcher Qualität das da am Ende rauskommt, aber wenn du irgendwie so in Richtung,
oder Datamining oder irgendetwas geht, gehst du was ja äh dann noch am besten in Form von Macht und macht Missbrauch geht, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass auf der ähm,
auf der Matte steht, ne.
Ja, so war's auch hier. Ähm und wie man sich denken kann, äh läuft nicht so geil, also in so einem ersten Durchlauf, als es darum ging, fünftausend äh Impfdosen schnell mal zu verteilen.
Haben nur sieben von tausenddreihundert äh Ärzten, die in der Corona-Intensivpflege tätig sind, haben wir überhaupt eine Zuteilung bekommen.
Großer der der Impfung ging an Verwaltungsangestellte oder an Mediziner die ihre Sprechstunde online abhielten. Also,
hat hat super funktioniert. Gab dann auch gleich äh eine Demo von Ärzten, die dann mit so Schildern rumgelaufen, so drauf äh stand äh,
Dem kann ich mich nur anschließen.
Aber genau er da ist natürlich äh also da ist das ist kann ich schon verstehen, dass das so ein Geschäft so ein Einwendungszweck ist, wo sich denkt, egal, das ist genau für uns, ja, weil.
Riecht nach Ärger, ja und riecht nach alle sind happy, wenn sie am Ende sagen können, war der Computer
ja? Und ob das dann gut oder schlecht ist, ist dann irgendwie auch zweitrangig. Insofern kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass hier genau da sagt so, hm, warte mal, das kann eigentlich nicht schief gehen, weil
egal was da rauskommt, also am Ende muss nur die Zahlen stimmen, ja? Hauptsache wir haben Hauptsache wir haben den Impfstoff irgendjemand zugeteilt, ja?
Oh je. Okay, dann kommen wir jetzt mal ähm das ist das ein Thema, was äh.
Wir ähm was jetzt schon etwas älter ist und deswegen hier am Ende der Sendung kommt und zwar.
Von hier in unseren Sendungen ja unter anderem von Julia Reeder und von Thomas Lohninger als das Thema zwanzig einundzwanzig angekündigt ist ja der Digital Services act und der.
Digital Markets Act, ja? Also das.
Corona.
Nee, Corona ist ja vorbei. Ist ja äh war ja Silvester jetzt so.
Genau.
Und ähm da soll also das, was äh also Hashtag Plattformregulierung Hashtag
DSA, Hashtag DMA, also achso und natürlich hier Patrick Breyer hatte das natürlich auch nochmal angesprochen, als er
bei uns in der Sendung, weil das ist das große Thema jetzt, ja? Und der soll, damit soll nichts anderes geregelt werden als im Prinzip,
die Plattformen. Und ähm da gab's wurde jetzt ähm.
Irgendwann, ich weiß nicht, ob der den ersten oder zweiten Dezemberwoche muss das gewesen sein, ist dann erstmals der Kommissionsentwurf ähm,
veröffentlicht worden.
Genau am siebten Dezember. Ich hatte mir das sogar in den Kalender eingetragen. Ähm Vorstellung des DSA,
DMA. Und jetzt, das, ne, kommt aus der Kommission und ähm.
Wir hatten jetzt in letzter Zeit natürlich relativ wenig Hoffnung, dass aus der EU in Sachen Plattformen Regulierungen und Vorgaben.
Besonders feine Sachen kommen, ja? Wir hatten die Upload-Filter, wir hatten die Diskussion um die äh Online Regulation. Wir hatten.
Und haben immer noch.
Den Angriff auf Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung, ja? Und jetzt soll hier diese ähm Verordnung kommen, ähm,
die ne, wie es immer so ist, die Einheitlichkeit im Binnenmarkt sichern soll und äh,
in dem Bereich sind natürlich nationale Alleingänge ungünstig, wie zum Beispiel das Netzwerk,
Durchsetzungsgesetz, weil das ja dann nur für Deutschland gilt und für die Niederländische schon nicht mehr. Das schafft eben Widersprüche und Uneinheitlichkeit in diesem europäischen Binnenmarkt und ähm deswegen,
will man das jetzt hier einmal versuchen, die wichtigen Züge zu vereinheitlichen. Und.
Es ist ja jetzt so, dass wir durchaus mit diesen großen Plattformen einige gesellschaftliche Probleme haben, ja, also die jetzt über irgendwie einzelne Dinge hinausgehen, ne? Äh Hassrede.
Desinformationskampagnen, die allgemeine äh Monopolbildung dieser Plattform und die Bedeutung, die sie in unserem Leben äh,
Entfalten sind ja nur einige Beispiele dafür, dass wir hier ja ungetüme gerade haben, die,
auf jeden Fall auf die eine oder andere Weise irgendwie reguliert werden müssen, um nicht ja am Ende,
Demokratie und äh Wirtschaftssystem irgendwie vollständig,
aufzufressen oder sich zu vereinnahmen. Und mit dem DSA und den DMA sollen also jetzt als Verordnung, also sofort in der,
EU einheitlich geltendes Recht, äh Regeln geschafft werden, die deswegen auch so eine große Bedeutung haben.
Und diese Regeln sollen natürlich auch für diejenigen äh Plattformen gelten, die im Ausland ansässig sind,
und aber in den in der EU ihre Dienste anbieten.
Und ich ähm habe das selber natürlich einige Sachen zu gelesen, aber ich stütze mich jetzt mal hier primär oft äh die Einschätzung von Julia Reeder, die natürlich schon.
Noch, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, als dieser DSA-DMA und diese Debatte losging, war sie ja auch noch äh Parlamentarierin und äh also schätze ich fühle ich so, ja, mein Palantier sagt mir, das müsste so gewesen sein.
Ein inneres hier.
Mein innerer, mein innerer kleiner auf äh anekdotischer Datenbasis. Ähm,
macht diese hat diese nebulöse Erinnerung gebaut, ja? Und der.
Sagt sie das zumindest ist schon mal erfreulich ist, dass überhaupt hier Meinungsinformations äh diskriminierungsfreiheit äh Grundrechte, Kater,
überhaupt Erwähnungen finden und zwar relativ früh und ähm dann eine Transparenz gefordert wird für Modulationsregeln und Durchsetzungsmechanismen. Hat sie ein schönes Beispiel und sagt quasi, ne, wenn du jetzt in einem Kochforum,
of Toppic, politischen Kommentar machst,
und da drin die Queen beleidigst, ja? Und dann ähm dieser Kommentar, was weiß ich, in den Off Topic Bereich verschoben wird oder gelöscht wird, wegen Majestätsbeleidigungen, ja, dann äh muss muss diese Regel, nach der das stattfindet, ähm.
Eben bevor er transparent und klar sein und zweitens muss es auch durchaus möglich sein, dass dieses Kochforum dich jetzt zum dir gegenüber zum Beispiel eine Regel durchsetzt, die sagt, das sind Kochforum und kein Politikforum, ja? Ähm aber.
Eben diese Regeln und Durchsetzungsmechanismen müssen klar benannt sein und wenn du automatische Filtersysteme verwendest, muss das auch öffentlich gemacht werden. Hm.
Das ist, denke ich
man hat ja sehr häufig so Fälle, dass irgendwie auf Twitter plötzlich Accounts gesperrt werden, ohne äh Angabe von Gründen, ja? Und,
da denke ich genau diesen Bereich, der auf jeden Fall problematisch ist, dem wir da begegnet,
Wie gesagt, nicht, dass dem ein Ende bereitet wird, aber nur, dass eben die Regeln und die Durchsetzungsmechanismen,
klar benannt werden müssen. Und das heißt natürlich auch, wenn die klar benannt sind, dann kannst du natürlich auch, wenn irgendwas passiert, was davon nicht gedeckt ist, dich beschweren, beziehungsweise wenn die Regeln unfair sind,
dich gegen diese Regeln zur Wehr setzen. Das ist, denke ich, hier die Basis. Ähm dann sagt sie, es geht,
geht natürlich auch um diese ganze Notes und Takedown Geschichte. Das ist immer das, ne? Du hast einen illegalen Inhalt als Hoster, wie hast darauf hingewiesen, was dann, ja? Und da sagt sie, ja, Upload-Filter werden nicht verpflichtend, aber so wie diese,
Verordnung in dieser aktuellen, in dem aktuellen Kommissionsentwurf gestaltet ist, werden die begünstigt.
Also du musst als Hosting Provider eine Meldestelle für illegale Inhalte anbieten.
Und das ist natürlich gut. Du musst ebenfalls eine Beschwerdestelle anbieten, ähm für Leute, die also für Menschen, die sich,
gegen.
Eine Löschung wehren wollen, also nicht nur das Recht, etwas zu melden und du nimmst es dann offline, sondern auch äh das Recht der Betroffenen sich dagegen zu wehren. Musst du ähm,
sicherstellen. Ja und das könnte potenziell ähm.
Ja dieses in den USA hast du das mit den DMCA Take Downs eben nicht unbedingt, dass du dich dagegen wehren kannst, ne? Also wenn du jetzt auf YouTube wird ja dann, also,
Ich glaube, da kann man sich noch dagegen wehren, aber wenn du mal irgendwie, wenn wir uns an diesen Gitterfall erinnern, ne, dann musste Gitter erstmal einfach compline,
und musste dann seinen eigenen Mut sammeln, um um den Beschwerden, die da gegen diese YouTube-DL Sperrung waren, irgendwie zu entsprechen und das wird also hier eher in formale Anforderungen gegossen. Das ist.
Du kannst dich wehren, wenn du es bezahlen kannst, ne.
Ja, aber vor allem muss die Plattform dir die Möglichkeit biete,
Ja und das ist äh so nicht nennenswert vorgeschrieben. Ähm dann gibt's diesen Aspekt wer Kindesmissbrauch meldet, muss sich nicht selber identifizieren. Das soll also, ne? Die Angst vor Strafverfolgung ähm senken.
Ja, kann natürlich auch potenziell, wenn du solche Meldungen vollständig äh anonym wirklich ermöglichst, dazu führen, dass die missbraucht werden müssen, die dann klären.
Und Julia sieht als Problem an, eine ausreichend präzise begründete Meldung.
Führt zur Haftung der Plattform, wenn sie nicht unverzüglich entfernt. Und dieses.
Das Löschen automatisiert umzusetzen und zwar voll automatisiert umzusetzen ist ausdrücklich erlaubt. Mit anderen Worten, äh du könntest jetzt irgendwie und ich glaube, mein Eindruck ist, dass YouTube das auch macht, ja, dass sie,
automatisierte Urheberansprüche,
erstens präventiv durchsetzen und zweitens irgendwie die großen Rechteinhaber diesen priviligierten Zugang haben zu YouTube, wo sie,
im Prinzip alles sofort weglegen können, ja? Und YouTube sagt, alles klar komm, wenn du das machst, haben wir beide weniger Ärger, wenn wir dir einfach einen Löschknopf geben,
und dieses Missbrauchspotential ist ja schon bekannt.
Und äh führt ja auch regelmäßig zu Problemen, ja? Ähm also da sagt sie.
Das könnte äh also die Probleme, die man da jetzt schon gesehen hat, die denen wird damit auf jeden Fall nicht begegnet. Und,
Argument kann man äh sicherlich,
bringen. Andererseits ist das natürlich auch wirklich ein zweischneidiges Schwert, weil es ja nun mal tatsächlich so ist, wenn jetzt die Rechte eines rechten Inhabers dann tatsächlich verletzt sind, ist für,
Alle Beteiligten halt am besten ist, äh wenn.
Der dem Anspruch auch so schnell wie möglich entsprochen wird. Und da gibt's aber jetzt, denke ich, eine viel viel interessanteres und auch ein sehr kluges äh Konzept, nämlich eine Transparenzpflicht. Also, Sperrungen müssen begründet werden,
und es muss über die Sperrung und Sperrbegründung eine zentrale, anonyme Datenbank geben.
Die für alle öffentlich zugänglich ist. Und das ist natürlich dann ganz schön, dass du eben eine allgemeine Transparenz darüber erlangen kannst, wenn irgendwo ausufernder Missbrauch zu erkennen ist. Also das,
ähm,
sehr äh ist schon sehr interessant. Diese Transparenzpflicht geht aber noch viel weiter zum Aspekt, den ich dann sehr spannend finde. Plattformen müssen Nutzerinnen darüber informieren.
Warum ihnen bestimmte Werbung angezeigt wird? Wie oft Accounts suspendiert wurden,
und was die Ergebnisse von Beschwerden über Inhalte und Accountsperrungen waren. Also all dieser Kram muss öffentlich gemacht werden.
Und da fände ich's jetzt mal echt spannend, wenn wenn du irgendwie ähm.
Untersuchst, warum dir bestimmte Werbung angezeigt wird, ne, also
es ist natürlich so, diese Daten werden sehr kryptisch sein und für die meisten Leute nicht interpretierbar, aber ich bin mal interessiert daran, was so Daten journalistinnen äh daraus machen könnten. Insbesondere spannend,
Plattform mit mehr als fünfundvierzig Millionen monatlichen Usern müssen eine öffentliche Datenbank aller geschalteten Werbung,
inklusive Reichweite und Zielgruppen anbieten. Und sie müssen eine regelmäßige Risikoanalyse hinsichtlich politischer Einflussnahme oder Gefahr für die öffentliche Gesundheit machen.
Das wird spannend. Und wenn die Datenbank öffentlich ist
ui ui ui ui ui, also dann dann da bin ich echt mal gespannt. Das wird den ein oder anderen echt spannenden äh CCC-Vortrag geben. Wenn das so wie's da steht, äh auch tatsächlich durchkommt. Das wäre wirklich mal spannend. Also da muss ich wirklich sagen, das klingt für mich echt sinnvoll.
Eine öffentliche Datenbank aller geschalteten Werbung inklusive Reichweite und Zielgruppen. Oha.
Also ich meine, das das wird erstmal ein Datensatz, ja. Also mal gucken, ja. Also ich äh bin mal gespannt. Aber ich meine, na ja, ein andererseits ist das natürlich auch zumutbar, weil die haben ja eh eine Datenbank, wo die ganze Werbung drin ist,
können sie die natürlich auch öffentlich machen.
Wissen das.
Also das könnte ähm das könnte ein Feld sein für Datenjournalist.
Heißt Facebook muss jetzt irgendwie öffentlich dokumentieren, für wen da Werbung gemacht wird und dann welche.
Moment, müsst T, wenn diese Verordnung in Kraft tritt und so weiter und so fort. Ja, also,
Es wurde ja schon mehrmals gesagt, dass ähm das Lobby-Aufkommen, die Lobby-Investitionen äh zur DSGVO ein Bruchteil sein werden von dem, was Unternehmen jetzt auf diese,
ähm auf diese in diesen Digital Services Act werfen werden.
Da werden wahrscheinlich neue äh ganz neue Wohnblöcke gebaut für die ganzen Lobbyist, die Google da jetzt hinschickt, ja.
Grundstückspreise explodieren.
Okay, das war ganz interessant. Wenn Marktplätze müssen Verkäufer, Identitäten prüfen bei Bedarf rausrücken und irgendwie transparent machen, wenn sie irgendwie
anbieten. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, da meinen die wahrscheinlich irgendwie so, wenn,
Amazon irgendwie Partys hat oder so. Mir ist das nicht ganz klar. Ich persönlich bin nicht so begeistert davon
wenn eBay jetzt irgendwie, was ich für einen Marktplatz halte, da die Identitäten prüft und bei Bedarf rausrückt. Ähm.
Weil das jetzt zum Beispiel auch wieder potentielles Missbrauch äh äh.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, das,
warum das da drin steht, ist ja eigentlich klar. Also ich meine, wenn du dir mal anschaust, was so äh ist da derzeit auf diesen Marktplätzen bei Verkäufer, da hast du halt diese ganzen Shadow-Verkäufer, die dann halt,
äh äh Sachen verkaufen, äh so Produkte et cetera,
und äh da gab's auch hier Birkenstock äh Urteile und so weiter. Also das ist äh ist ein echtes Problem, ne? Auch diese ganze Umsatzsteuer Transparenz et cetera
und äh in dem Moment, wo die Plattform, ich finde das auch ehrlich gesagt absolut legitim. Also ich finde so einen Marktplatz.
Einfach klar rausrücken mit wer wer verkauft da was? Was.
Ja, vor allem, wenn wenn insbesondere so mit mit äh Chinaprodukten und so, also das scheint ja auch ein riesiges Problem zu sein. Ich.
Ja, das ist ein riesiges.
Dass das irgendwelche, ja, Produkt, Fakes und so irgendwie über Amazon verballert werden.
Und was da auch an Umsatzsteuer verloren geht, also ich meine, das ist ja nun nun real, ne? Da da geht dem äh entgeht dem Staat einfach viel der Umsatzkohle, die ihm einfach zusteht, so. Schauen wir mal so sehen.
Ja und dann gibt's noch natürlich das gesamte Ding, ja, also in Anführungszeichen, die digitale Höchststrafe, die Accountsperrung, ja, da sollen also die Plattformen verpflichtet werden.
Verpflichtet werden. Accounts bei wiederholten Gesetzesverstößen nach einer Verwarnung zu sperren.
Ja, das wäre also eine Strikeriegel,
Ähm und ähm na das führt natürlich auch äh ganz gerne mal zu Problemen, insbesondere, wenn du,
jetzt spontan und koordiniert Beschwerden über alte Inhalte,
loslässt, ne? Dass du jemanden relativ schnell ähm in laufen lassen kannst und die Person dann ihren Account los ist. Und das ist ja für so eine für so eine Influencerin.
Potentiellen Problemen, ja, die,
muss hier erstmal wieder eine ganze Menge Nägel lackieren, um so viele Follower unter einen neuen Account zu haben, ja. Und ähm.
Insofern denke ich, da muss auch natürlich sehr umsichtig äh äh reguliert werden, dass es einerseits,
klar eine Ahnung gibt bei Leuten, die es die regelmäßig verstoßen, aber gleichzeitig, dass die natürlich auch entsprechend ähm ja, einen Rechtsweg haben gegen solche folgenschweren Entscheidungen, ja?
Ähm insgesamt.
Sagt Julia, dass das schon jetzt echt irgendwie einen Sinneswandel der Kommission zeigt, ja, von der.
Plattform, Nutzerinnen.
Als Konsument hin und äh potentielle Rechtsbrecherinnen zu einem Subjekt, dem auch Rechte wie Meinungsfreiheit und so weiter anerkannt werden und,
der Schutz dieser Rechte irgendwie sich in einer festen Verordnung wiederfinden soll. Ähm,
Also da gibt's eine verhalten positive äh,
Stimmung. Gleichzeitig sagt sie natürlich auch, ne, also das, was irgendwie gebaut wurde durch Urheberrechtsreform und Terrec und so. Das wird dadurch nicht ungeschehen, weil eine sektorspezifische Regelung eben Vorrang hat vor dem,
vor dem Digital Services act. Also das was wir bis jetzt schon haben, wird selbst wenn der Digital Services Act jetzt liberaler wäre, dadurch nicht ungeschehen. Ähm.
Und ein Aspekt, den sie noch sagt, ähm bei dieser äh bei diesen Plattformen größer fünfundvierzig Millionen monatlicher User, wo eben größere,
Anforderungen hinsichtlich der Transparenzpflicht und na? Reaktionszeiten bestehen, dass das natürlich zum Beispiel für sowas wie die Wikipedia ähm
interessant ist äh oder problematisch ist, weil die Wikipedia riesengroß ist, Millionen Nutzerinnen im Monat hat oder wahrscheinlich Milliarden.
Aber eben kein gewinnstrebendes Unternehmen ist, sondern eben ein ein riesiges Community-Projekt, was da von einer relativ kleinen Foundation ähm getragen und administriert wird. Und äh,
Da müsste natürlich, wenn die jetzt irgendwie die gleichen.
Ja rechtlichen Anforderungen und Transparenzpflichten und Beschwerdestellen und juristischen Zinnober wie Facebook haben, dann äh ist das natürlich potenziell ein Problem.
Ähm aber insgesamt erstmal verhalten positiv.
Doch auch mal nicht, ist doch nicht schlecht, so Tim, vielleicht kommen ja doch noch die goldenen zwanzig.
Es zeichnet sich schon was ab.
Nicht, nicht in den, nicht in den deutschen Impfzahlen, aber.
Hör mir auf.
Ansonsten vielleicht.
Hör mir auf. Impfthema.
Behandeln wir jetzt nicht. Das.
Behandeln wir nicht.
Nur so nebenbei. Gut, dann haben wir's, oder?
Aber aber äh also spannend finde ich ja an dieser ganzen Impfdebatte ja jetzt, ne, dass die ganzen Impfgegner von der AfD sie jetzt trotzdem sich aufregen müssen, dass andere die Impfung zuerst kriegen, dass das gönne ich denen so richtig.
Ich meine, die haben jetzt eh so ein echtes Schwubelproblem, ne? Weil sie ja die ganze Zeit irgendwie den Virus, den es ja eigentlich gar nicht gibt, ja, da wird aber jetzt zu wenig dafür getan,
Um Impfung in ausreichender Zahl zu machen, das wird äh kritisiert, die ja total gefährlich sind und die man ja nicht nehmen sollte. Also.
Das ist oh das ist super dir anzuschauen. Fällt mir übrigens ein, was ich auch sehr schön fand, ähm es war, glaube ich, noch letztes Jahr, da haben.
Bundestagsabgeordnete aller Fraktionen außer der AfD. Ähm,
eine äh die Forderung formuliert, das äh Assange freigelassen wird, ja? Also das ist sind Abgeordnete von der Linken, von der FDP, von der CDU, SPD und Grüne, ja? Und diese,
vor dieses Statement der Arbeitsgruppe wird eingeleitet mit
als gemeinsame Initiative von Abgeordneten aller demokratischen Fraktionen im Deutschen Bundestag möchten wir ein klares Zeichen setzen für den Schutz der Meinungs- und Pressefreiheit, die durch die drohende
Auslieferung von Julian Assange gefährdet ist. Das finde ich sehr schön.
Nicht dabei, ne?
Die CDU war auch dabei. Ja, also alle außer AfD und diese als Gemeinde Initiative von Abgeordneten, aller demokratischen Fraktionen. Ich kannte ja schon den äh, also die Formulierung, die demokratische äh Opposition.
Ähm das ist schon so etabliert, ähm um eben nicht immer zu sagen, die Opposition fordert, weil,
da gibt's eben die die demokratische Opposition und die.
Ansammlung.
Wie nennt man das? Ja, die Ansammlung frustrierter Deutscher und äh wie würde man das sagen? Die Demokratieskeptiker, ja? Ähm,
sich ja wahrscheinlich selber bezeichnen, die selber denken in Demokratieskeptiker, he? Ähm
Deswegen also die alle demokratischen Fraktionen des Deutschen Bundestags finde ich sehr schön diese diese Formulierung.
Realitätsleugner. Ach, na ja gut, über die regen wir uns jetzt mal nicht auf. So und jetzt machen wir Schluss.
Jetzt machen wir Schluss und ähm aber, da ich die Sendung ja noch vorbereitet habe im letzten Jahr.
Doch natürlich, doch, muss sein. Tim, ich habe gesagt, das endet,
im neuen Jahr und äh für diejenigen, die den noch ganz im, am Ende, so die, die ähm.
Die Nachzügler, sagen wir mal, ja, die dann noch ein ein sich ein Dankeschön auf den letzten Metern.
Noch nicht ganz so goldenen zwanzig zwanzigern verdient haben.
Ähm ein letztes Mal persönlichen Dank ähm ab jetzt nur noch persönlichen Dank, wenn ihr mir,
wenn ihr mir kontaktiert und dann kriegt ihr auf dem Weg persönlichen Dank geht an Werner Jendrik, Lorenz, Robin, Christian,
Markus, Volker und Paul und an dieser Stelle ähm möchte ich auch nochmal äh.
Ganz allgemein mich bedanken bei Thomas Lohninger, der ja hier sehr regelmäßig äh wichtig zur Sendung beiträgt.
Und Andre Meister, der das in letzter Zeit äh viel zu selten macht, insofern äh würde ich sagen, Tadel, Tadel, an danken tadelnder Dank an Andre Meister.
Ach, schön. Und ich bedanke mich auch mal. Ich bedanke mich.
Fängst du damit an oder was?
Ja, jetzt bist du ja durch, jetzt kann ich.
Erst redest du mir das aus und.
Ja, das äh die Zeiten ändern sich, ne? Jetzt kommen die goldenen Zwanziger. Jetzt darf ich Danke sagen.
Nö, ich wollte mich einfach nur mal so bei unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern, so ganz im Allgemeinen bedanken, weil ich halt einfach immer wieder sehe, wir werden so viel
zitiert und es wird hingewiesen auf uns wird vor allem auch sehr aufmerksam zugehört und es wird auch sehr aufmerksam kommentiert und den wird's ja nicht anders gehen als mir, dass man so im äh Gespräch hier und da, hinten rum und immer mal wieder äh so auch ausm direkt
ein Feedback von irgendwelchen Leuten doch äh einiges an Wertschätzung erfährt.
Und das ähm finde ich ist äh etwas, was man durchaus nochmal herausstellen kann. Wir nehmen das wahr,
und wir wissen das auch zu schätzen und ähm finden das gut und wollen auch, dass das so bleibt und deswegen werden wir jetzt weiter senden dieses Jahr.
Wir haben übrigens extrem viele Sendungen rausgehauen letztes Jahr. Ich glaube, das war auch unser Rekord.
Wir hatten ja auch sonst nichts zu tun.
Ähm ich habe jetzt die genaue Zahl grad nicht am Start, aber es war ein, glaube ich, gut warte mal, doch, ich habe die genaue Zahl am Start und zwar.
Fünfzig, fünfzig Sendungen haben wir gemacht. Ja, wirklich fast jede Woche was rausgehauen.
Das ist äh das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Ja.
Uiuiuiui. Das wird das wird schwer zu toppen. Und wir hätten ja fast einundfünfzig geschafft. Also, wenn wir noch, wenn wir noch eine mehr gemacht hätten.
Ja, aber haben wir ja nicht.
Hätte ich das gewusst. Okay, ja.
Da, da war ja Kongress, das ging ja nicht.
Der war nicht Kongress, da war RC drei.
Ja ja, aber Chaos.
Auf jeden Fall auch, ja.
Leute, gut, dann äh auf ein erfolgreiches zwanzig einundzwanzig mit euch und ähm dann feiern wir auch irgendwann mal wieder richtig. Jetzt erstmal.
Ja äh wenn wir jetzt wenn wir jetzt die die Erscheinungsfrequenz ein bisschen drosseln, meinst du, dann können wir eine LNP vierhundert.
Ach so, wir zögern das jetzt einfach raus. Pass auf. Hände kurve.
Also sei mal mit den mit mit Genesenen und Geimpften natürlich nur, ist klar, ne?
Fünfundzwanzig haben wir noch, also sagen wir machen jetzt nur noch eine im Monat. Dann vor zwei Jahren.
Ach so. Nein, halbes Jahr. Also im halben Jahr wäre ich im halben Jahr nicht geimpft, wäre der geimpft bin, dann werde ich auch langsam ein bisschen knatschig. Ich ich habe ja jetzt erst mal so die erste Januarwoche habe ich ja auch gesagt, so ich bin total geduldig, ne?
Und sehe das auch völlig ein, dass da erstmal ein paar andere vor mir dran sind, aber so.
Jetzt wirst du langsam unruhig.
Ja, jetzt werde ich unruhig. Nee, aber so nach im halben Jahr muss dann schon auch der Spanu.
Na ja, fünfundzwanzig Sendungen ist, ist, ist ungefähr ein halbes Jahr, so, ne, mit ein bisschen Sommer noch dazu. Mal gucken, vielleicht wird das ja was.
Open Air in Kleingruppen oder so.
Jeder in seinem eigenen Ballon ja.
Ja oder? Wir lassen uns, wir lassen uns helfen von Leuten, die ähm schon bei der RC drei ihr Können bewiesen haben und äh lassen uns von ein paar Leuten dabei unterstützen, ein Online-Event zu bauen.
Nee, nächster Online-Event.
Nee, es muss um einfach mal was mit, mit, mit, mit Schweiß und Atem zu tun haben, sonst, sonst findet das irgendwie nicht statt, so. Aber wir machen das, wenn wenn jede Zelle unseres Körpers glücklich ist,
Genau, dann machen wir das.
Jetzt haben wir auch ein Auto. Tschau, tschau.
Genau. Tschüss Leute.